nice to see you Mr chief justice
thank you
looks like you've got some handouts
which Mr Hoffman if
okay
foreign
Justice if you'd like to introduce some
of the folks you brought with you and
be great
for the record my name is Gordon
McDonald I'm the Chief Justice with me
today is the Chief Justice of the
Superior Court Tina NATO the
administrative judge of the Circuit
Court David King and the director of the
administrative office of the courts
Diane Martin we prepared a handout and
um if it's with the Indulgence of the
chair and members of division one I'd
like to run through it we had planned to
do a little bit of a tag team on that if
that's okay okay uh
so uh
first page or second page page two
today's presentation way I would like to
proceed Mr chairman is to give an
overview of the judicial branch for the
for the benefit of the members of the
division then talk about uh assessing
the branches needs and specifically
we're going to talk about
um something called the weighted
caseload study that was performed in
last year or 2022 then talk a little bit
about how
we're trying to deliver Innovations in
the way we deliver our services to the
state talk about our access to Justice
crisis and what we're doing to remediate
that in our efforts to reach out to the
communities we serve
and we're open for questions at any time
next page is our mission statement
I won't dwell on that but the committee
will have that
um so let's go to slide four
which is uh beginning of our overview of
the judicial branch the judicial branch
is comprised of two trial courts the
superior court and the Circuit Court
one Appellate Court which is the Supreme
Court
and uh we are all supported by the
administrative office of the Courts
and I'd like to go through Court by
court and just give some background for
members of the committee I invite judge
king up here to talk about uh division
of the Circuit Court
good morning comes with division one my
name is David King I'm the
administrative judge as the chief just
said so the circuit court is uh
the quote where most people go when they
go to court in New Hampshire we have
about 90 percent of the cases uh we have
courthouses in 34 locations around the
state and we have uh the jurisdiction
that the legislature gives us and
nothing beyond that so you tell us what
we do and in many instances how long we
have to do it and how many days we have
to resolve the cases and we follow your
lead on that so you can see on uh the
next slide slide seven my pages are off
our locations so there's a courthouse
near you that was been that was the
mission of the old district court and
many of those locations are the same
we're in all 10 counties and many
counties were co-located with the
superior court but in a lot of the more
rural areas we have Standalone
courthouses we are broken into divisions
which just to remind many of you were
here in 2011. representative Wiley was
chair of the finance committee at that
time when we created the circuit court
and what we did it back then is we took
the Probate Court which was Standalone
Court the district court and the Family
Division and we combined them into one
it was a time of budget issues in the
state and trying to be good stewards of
the court of the state's money we felt
this was a way to create some innovative
ways to save money and we went at that
time from 115 clerks and deputies down
to 52 in a relatively short period of
time about three months actually and
we've been operating in that manner ever
since but the legislature in creating
the Circuit Court kept the three
separate divisions so we have a probate
division a district Division and a
Family Division so
from the outside it doesn't look much
different but from the inside we have a
lot less bodies than we used to have
particularly in management
on the next slide slide eight you can
see where our cases come from we have
roughly 125 000 new cases a year in the
Circuit Court to process and get through
the system in another 17 000 or so
reopened cases that come back whether
they are parenting cases or things of
that nature that have to be handled as
well each of those circles is a case
type that the legislature has given us
the jurisdiction to deal with on the
next slide are the judicial officers
that we have in the Circuit Court when
the Circuit Court was created in 2011
the statute specifically says that the
number of Judges shall be no less than
the number of authorized traditional and
Master positions at the time and so we
always talk about the full-time judicial
officers and those numbers have gone up
in 2011
we had we were authorized for 45
full-time judicial officers at that time
we had 13 marital Masters which are
which are in that number we now have no
more marital masses they're gone but
important for uh discussion this morning
I also want to remind you at that time
we had 29 part-time judges in the
circuit court and part-time simply means
that they're not a full-time judicial
officer with benefits they get paid by
the day or per diem but many of those
part-time judges those 29 part-time
judges actually worked 224 days a year
they just didn't get health insurance
paid vacation and the benefits that the
full-time judges received so that was
the way that we were able to cover that
huge volume of cases today we're down to
six part-time judges so while we have
more full-time judges than we had in
2011 we went we've gone from 74 judges
who were people that we could call at
any given time to get on the bench and
judge who it remembers those days now
we're down to 47. so when we talk about
the numbers and the and the need under
the weighted caseload study I just want
you to keep in mind that although we
have all many more full-time judges we
don't have as many bodies as we had back
in 2011.
thank you judge king
chichester's NATO
give a background on the Superior Court
thank you chief and uh good morning
everyone thank you so much for having us
here today it's a pleasure to be back
before you and talk about the court
system I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the Superior Court
jurisdiction and in the Superior Court
we handle mostly what we handle are all
a jury trial so that's where jury trials
take place and we have jurisdiction over
major felonies like homicide sexual
assaults burglaries theft drug related
charges and then we also have
jurisdiction over civil cases that
involve medical malpractice car
accidents negligence cases and you can
see the jurisdictional amounts in our
slide on on slide 11 and we also handle
misdemeanor appeals from the Circuit
Court Division and what I would always
say also say is although we have jury
trials that's the bulk of what we do
judges also conduct bench trials often
and those might involve complex civil
matters it involves planning board
appeals zoning board appeals contract
disputes non-competition Clauses and
those those cases require judges to
issue orders that can be anywhere from
four pages to 40 pages long and our jury
trials they can last from anywhere from
a two-day jury trial to a six week jury
trial if it's a homicide so that gives
you sort of a sense of of what we do in
the superior court and you can see on
slide 12 we have 11 Superior Court
locations obviously you know there are
10 counties and Hillsborough counties
broken up into two districts so we have
two locations in Hillsborough County and
that we have three clerks that cover two
courts they handle two courts so co-ops
and Grafton county is managed by one
clerk Sullivan and Cheshire county is
managed by another Clerk and uh belnap
and
um Carroll County are handled by one
single clerk the rest have a clerk per
court so that gives you some sense of
what our court organization looks like
and then on slide 13 you can see our
annual filings they're a lot less than
circuit court but they're larger and can
sometimes be more complicated so about
seventeen thousand per year
and you will see on the next page that
we have 22 full-time Superior Court
judges one of them is the Chief Justice
that's me so I handle most
administrative matters but I also try to
sit a lot so I can be in the court
seeing what's going on understanding
what's going on when I was first
appointed back in 1996 the next judge
appointed after me came seven years
later and since I've been Chief over the
past 11 years we've had almost 18 new
judges cycled through I think circuit
court has had the same sort of turnover
so we have a lot of new judges a lot of
new people to train and get up and
running and one thing I will tell you is
that when I TR when I sit we have
another program that we started during
the pandemic called criminal mediation
and so I handle a lot of those where
parties have the opportunity to come to
a judge and talk for an hour or two
about their case and get it resolved
that way instead of waiting a longer
period of time for a jury trial sitting
judges don't have a couple of hours to
take with uh with with the party so I'll
go to Hillsborough North or Hillsborough
South and do maybe six a day twice a
month and that helps to keep up with the
with the backlog so that's just a
snapshot of what we do when we get back
to it I'll tell you a little bit more
about treatment courts
thank you chichester's NATO so you've
heard about our two trial courts in
Circuit Court the Superior Court we have
one appellate court it's called the
Supreme Court and on page 16 just an
overview we have five justices for
associate justices and one chief justice
we sit in Concord we sit all year round
and the Chief Justice in addition to my
judicial duties I have overall
responsibility for the judicial branch
uh the Supreme Court also has various
administrative functions including
liaison with the bar association
development of core rules uh oversight
of various uh disciplinary committees
and so on next slide you can see our
filings from 2021 and I will tell you
that the data from 2022 are in we just
haven't made a slide our accused filings
are going up there was a bit of a dip
from the pandemic but you can you can
see that we in 2021 625 cases were
disposed of one way or another
we all our arguments we had
we had them yesterday they were all live
and streamed they were before the
pandemic and they are continue to be and
um
everything all our opinions and orders
are also published on our website
finally that last element of the
judicial branch I just want to give you
an overview of is the administrative
office of the courts and our director
Diane Martin is here to give you a brief
overview
19.
I come from the executive branch prior
to this role so I like to think of the
administrative office of the Court says
the department of administrative
Services mixed with the Department of
Information Technology throw in a little
bit of general counsel and some of the
other functions it's it's somewhat of an
unknown entity I think in the courts I
certainly wasn't aware of it but it
really provides all of the support that
all of the trial courts need to operate
so there are a number of departments
much like executive branch departments
although on a smaller scale that I just
want to run through
operations and audit so folks may not
know that we have an internal audit
division that actually conducts audits
of the trial courts and now is doing
um risk assessment of the whole branch
and focusing on some of our AOC
departments as well we have an excellent
Auditor in the division who came from
the LBA prior to this so he's really
transforming that function
fiscal accounting and accounting support
are if you're thinking of executive
branch agencies very much like the
business office in a large in a large
agency
general counsel and government relations
we have a two lawyers in that office who
support the whole Branch as far as
providing advice and counsel
HR we have an HR department much like
Personnel within the department of
administrative services that serves all
of the employees
Communications very small office within
the branch to support our Communications
with the public and members of the press
and then court security which is a very
large part of what we do in the
administrative office of the courts
there are
on any given day about 150 Court
security officers that are either per
diem or full-time officers most of them
are per diem
and finally information technology and
other unknown Department I think
um within the branch we have our own
information technology department that
supports all of the technology that's
necessary to run the courts which has
become an increasingly larger function
after the pandemic
thank you Diane judicial branch is
relatively complex with our location 40
or so locations around the state 700
plus full-time employees so the AOC
gives us tremendous support
so I'd like to shift now and focus on
on some of the fundamentals about how we
staff and how we determine how to staff
but first I want to talk about our
budget
um
74 of our budget is Personnel we we are
people uh delivering an essential
constitutionally mandated service to the
to the people of New Hampshire and as a
consequence as this division is well
aware when you're in the business of
personnel your costs are fixed health
insurance retirement plan workers comp
in addition to those Personnel related
uh cost centers we also transfer or or
reimburse the counties uh for Deputy
sheriffs that provide security in our in
our Superior Courts and we also um uh
transfer or pay the department of
administrative Services which provides
essentially our facilities
there is a bureau of Court facilities
and we work with them and many of our
locals many of our locations are
actually leased so we have rental
payments to make
so that's the broadest overview of our
budget and the key point there is we are
personnel
and and the issue that I want to spend
some time with with the division is how
do we determine
how many judges and Court staff are
needed to process cases in our trial
courts our two trial courts
and and to deliver in evidence-based
fact-based answer
did the judicial branch engaged in
something called a weighted caseload
study in 2022.
so
um if you go to slide 22 there are there
are a number of ways that that can be
used to determine how many judges are
needed any any given Place uh you could
do it by population you could do it by
the number of cases that are filed the
problem with the last that latter
methodology is some cases are more
complicated than others some cases take
more staff time and more judge time to
decide than others a complex felony
trial a complex homicide takes much more
time than a relatively routine small
claims case I mean that that is
seems self-evident and part of the
exercise the actually the essence of the
exercise of the way to caseload
methodology is to tease that out to
figure out how much time we need for
staff and judicial officers in a in 14
given case types and that's the that's
what we went through last year
um the next slide describes the basic
methodology and I won't Linger on that
except to say that the key variable that
we tried to determine was the actual
number of minutes
required for either staff or judges to
deal with the 14 different case types we
looked at
uh on slide 24 we have a brief history
of weighted caseload studies in New
Hampshire this methodology was endorsed
by this legislature in 2005. it's
actually embodied in statute
um the last weighted caseload
methodology a weighted caseload study
that was done the first
uh one that was done was in 2005 that
was also the last one that was done
our head count total full-time head
count dealing with cases in 2005 was 482
and uh when we did our Study last year
that comparable number was 514.
to uh produce the most
trustworthy
results that is most most faithful to
the methodology which is you which is
used by court systems around the country
we engaged something called the national
Center for state courts and I should say
just a footnote there that the
legislature did provide funding for this
study in 2019.
and we use that funding to engage the
national Center for state courts that's
based in Williamsburg Virginia it's in
part A consultancy for state courts in
part a think tank for a small
jurisdiction like us it's an absolutely
invaluable resource and they provided uh
they provided the the support and
guidance and and and ensured that we
were faithful to this methodology
they've performed a way to caseload
studies for judges in 35 States and for
staff in 24 States
so on the next slide slide 26 as I said
the key variable that we we saw it in
this study was to determine by case type
how much time was needed by either Court
processing staff or judges and on the
right side of the slide you're going to
see one example for one case type which
is small claims which is a case type
that exists in our Circuit Court
and um
the basic elements are laid out in this
chart we uh
we determined
that during the data collection period
which was six weeks at the beginning of
000 or so minutes were recorded by
judges as dealing with small claims
cases there were 29 days in our data
collection period and that
if you multiply those two numbers that
means we need
that that is that means that we we spent
770 minutes per working day on small
claims cases
uh for purposes of this study
we assumed
217 judicial working days and I just
want to footnote that I'll come back to
it later okay
um so our Statewide annualized minutes
for small claims cases is about a
hundred and sixty seven thousand
um and then you divide that by the
number of filings which during this
period was uh thirteen thousand about
thirteen thousand five hundred
and you come to this number at the
bottom which is 12.38 minutes that is
the average I stress that average amount
of time that a circuit court judge
spends
on a small claims case
so that you can see how that's a key
variable because we know how many cases
are filed every year and how many
minutes it takes for a judge to deal
with it so we know based on this data
how many judges we need just to deal
with small claims cases and it's about
2.3 judges just on small claims in our
Circuit Court and so we went through
this analysis across all these uh case
types 14 case types in both of our trial
courts
uh the next slide
is
um
it just reiterates what I've already
covered the data collection period was
from January to March of last year
and we were fully operational as trial
courts then we had come out of the
pandemic although the funding was
authorized in 2019 we wanted good data
and and
um by the by the beginning of last year
we were fully operational and we felt
comfortable that we were going to get
good solid data out of it we also needed
the data back in time for us to begin to
build our budget because this x is the
whole point of this exercise was to
inform our budget development process on
the right hand
of this slide you will see
that is the actual instrument it's a
little hard to read but that's the
actual instrument that our our judges
and Court staff dealt with for the 29
days of the data collection period and
they literally recorded their time by
case type
so at a level Set uh where we were at
the time of our study we had I mentioned
this earlier
514 full-time equivalents
and this is judges and staff that deal
with cases okay there are we have other
staff that don't deal with cases we're
just focused on case processing staff in
our two trial courts and you can see
they're broken down by Circuit and
Superior Court
um I I call the division's attention to
uh particularly the number of judicial
officers in the circuit court judge king
just told you we we have 41 now it was
actually 40 full-time judicial officers
in in
at the time of the study the reason that
says 44.32 is explained in the footnote
that as part of the study we included
some of our full-time part-time judges
as well as child support hearing
officers we have FTE equivalent of 1.77
and we also had the one marital Master
at that time so that I just want to call
it division's attention to that number
because I'll come back to it okay but
this gives you a baseline of the staff
that we had at the time we did the study
next slide is slide 29 and I think all
of us in leadership are so proud of this
that we had over the course of 29 days
complete 100 participation by our judges
and staff so that means that our data
have great integrity and uh it took our
staff are quite busy our judges are
quite busy and this was an additional
part of the day that we asked them to do
but we do get 100 participation
so on page 30 I want to begin
summarizing the results of our report
that was finalized in July and it goes
without saying if if the division wants
a copy of the report we will absolutely
provide it
um
the national Center found that we needed
a total of 500
rounding up 6
564 judicial officers and staff to deal
with cases so if our Baseline was
514 we need roughly 50 more judges and
staff
that's broken down by Circa cord about
37 positions in Superior Court 12
positions on the next slide you see that
broken down even more
by our two trial courts the Circuit
Court
concluded that we needed 65 judges
for a difference of 21.3 and please
footnote that I'm going to come back to
it
and in this in the Superior Court the
study concluded that we needed three and
a half additional judges I won't spend
time on the staff but you can see for
the most part we needed additional staff
in certain areas in just a few areas
there was a call for staff decrease
the next slide is critical
so that so the national Center concluded
we needed 50 additional judges and case
processing staff
but the study also concluded that our
clerks and Deputy clerks and managers
are doing the work of our case
processing staff
and that has it actually comes out to
about
57.3 full-time equivalent
Court processing staff work so our
Deputy clerks and clerks are in addition
to doing their jobs running courts they
are doing
the equivalent of 57.3
full-time equivalent
uh Court processing staff
so the basic number that we have is 50
judges
and staff
plus 57 staff is what the bottom line is
from the national Center in our report
the next slide I might invite judge king
up here for to walk through the next
slide which is 33.
um we need to we need to True up
the circuit court judge number
and
um
it's the Baseline number that was used
was 44.
the national Center concluded we needed
about 25 new judges
that needs to be adjusted downward
and that is because of personnel changes
and one very critical uh element of the
study that was not included which is
that we do have part-time per diem
judges there's six of them
and so you need to back out the hours
that they work and the there they are
variable each judge comes to us and says
we're going to be I would can do 150
hours I can do 200 hours it depends uh
or 200 days I can it depends so the data
before you in this chart on chart 33
trues up the number based on that
resource available to us and uh instead
of 25
that the national Center recommended
that the number once you do the math and
back out the resources that are
available to us is actually 17.
do you see that at the bottom of the
chart
did I get that right yes and so again
members of The Division I think it's
important to contrast where we are now
versus where we were in 2011 we have
a very small number of per diem judges
left uh one two three four of them have
been appointed to the Circuit Court and
uh they're all at the end of their
careers so to speak and they don't want
to work full-time they want to tell us
how many days they want to work which is
fine and we're grateful to have the days
but we really have been over the course
of the Circuit Court moving toward a
more full-time bench which I think makes
sense for the citizens of New Hampshire
more consistency and more predictability
and these three of these judges will be
retiring shortly
we schedule in the Circuit Court based
on Judge days so the weighted caseload
study tells us that we need 16
352 judge days in this calendar year 16
352 days of Judge time to move that 125
000 cases
when we put our schedule together for
2023 taking all of our full-time judges
the per diems that you see here
11 judges who are retired over the age
of 70 and another four senior active
judges who are retired but can still sit
as judges and said give us as many days
as you possibly can when we cobbled that
whole group together we were able to put
a schedule together with 10 518 days
out of a needed sixteen thousand and
change so uh I guess what that
demonstrates is we're significantly sure
of what we need to move that 125 000
cases and when your constituents call
and say you know it's taken me two years
to get a hearing and a divorce case or a
year in a small claims case
unfortunately
that's the truth and and I can provide
we didn't it didn't fit in the slides
but I do have a chart of the Circuit
Court by case type we know how many days
each different case type takes and we
basically have to triage and say all of
these cases have statutory deadlines we
have to do those and then those that
don't unfortunately get shuffled to the
side and we get to them when we can so
picking up on that uh if you turn to
slide 34.
uh
depicts exactly what judge king was
talking about
the the circuit court is is a court of
Highly specialized jurisdiction with
really detailed statutes that they
Implement many have statutory deadlines
many of the case types have statutory
deadlines and of course our
constitutional and and some other case
types have constitutionally required
deadlines
at the top you will see the statutorily
required the statutorily mandated
timelines those case types have
statutorily mandated timelines
abuse and neglect domestic violence some
won't go through the whole list but you
can see it there
so when judge king is
is trying to figure out how we take the
limited resources we have
and assign it to the work of the Circuit
Court these case types go to necessarily
go to the top of the pile because we
need to follow the law so what falls to
the bottom of the pile
divorce parenting small claims civil
inequity cases and if you go back to the
chart with all the circles on it you
will see that those are some of the
larger case types that the Circuit Court
deals with and it I think it goes
without saying that in a divorce and
parenting case
um people want answers they want
hearings they want just to take an
example and and they are as judge king
said
we're in a position where we're
necessarily having to delay scheduling
of hearings in contested divorce cases
just to take an example
um small claims cases also I I would
imagine you have heard from your
constituents about delays with respect
to that case type and it's just a
consequence of limited resources and
having to triage based on these timeline
driven cases
right and the other thing that it it
really means in reality is we're trying
to get to everything so a hearing and a
parenting case that really needs an hour
hearing or an hour and a half hearing
you might get 20 minutes and that's all
you have because there's another one
right behind it so we're trying to move
the cases but we're not giving folks the
time that they really need to present
their case it's not it puts the judges
and the staff in a very difficult
position but that's what we have to do
so I want to preview uh understanding
that the formal budget will be presented
next month preview what what we've asked
for the judicial branch has unique
there's actually a statute that governs
this our budget request is supposed to
be a pass-through to to the governor so
this is a preview with respect to
judicial resources that we have asked
for
um overall I will say on page 36 our
objectives in our budget requests that
you will see is to begin to address the
needs in the way to caseload study we
also need to
um we have taken a hard look at court
security and we need to to enhance our
court security and we need to as the
rest of state government respond to the
inflationary pressures that we're
feeling as an employer
but getting back to the or focusing on
that first bullet the point on slide 37
you'll see our budget request based on
the way to caseload study so we we've
asked for seven judges in the Circuit
Court of the 17 that that the study uh
determined that we needed and one uh
additional judge in the superior court
of the three and a half that
um
the study determined that we're needed
case staff a court staff is really a
critical uh Focus for us
um you can't it's one thing to add
judges but if you don't have the staff
that are supporting the judges and
making sure that the orders get out on
time and and the hearings get scheduled
it's it's ill-advised investment so
you'll recall that we have 57
full-time equivalent
uh
staff impounded in our clerks and Deputy
clerks across both of our trial courts
we're asking just on that we're asking
for 31 new cleric clerical staff in the
circuit court and one new
Court Clerk and four new clerical staff
in Superior and one new court clerk
Mr chief justice I do have a question
yes Mr chairman as you know
representative Lind has a bill in to
have a land use Superior Court judges
would that be the one that you're
requesting or would that be an
additional that that is the one where
we're the one okay thank you
while we're having a little short little
discussion are there any questions from
members of the uh representative Weiler
thank you Miss Mr chairman and chief
justice
we've added some new courts lately are
we going to have a problem with
courtrooms
no good
because that that gets pretty expensive
too
yes
we're we're confident we have the
facilities
necessary to accommodate the staff that
and Court judges that we're asking for
able to close one chord six figure here
last time last style is now closed when
Consolidated those cases into Brentwood
so we've eliminated that expense very
good thank you representative McGuire
has a question or two
I have a page
[Laughter]
um so on the study uh I didn't hear you
say how the numbers were created is it
is it it takes us 12 and a half minutes
to do this kind of case we have so many
cases therefore we need that many
minutes or is there any data involved
from other states right maybe in
Maine it only takes them 10 minutes for
this kind of case or something like that
therefore maybe we could be more
efficient or less efficient they answer
your question uh representative McGuire
is no we did not look at other states
um I I we the the basic variable was 29
days
of recording Time by judges and Court
staff I mean they recorded by case type
their day
and we took that and were able to
average out the minutes
um I I would respectfully submit I don't
know the comparative data I mean you're
raised a good point but I and I would
invite any member of this division to
visit any one of our circuit courts and
and observe for themselves
um just the time pressures that our
judges in both courts are under to deal
with these cases I think 12.38 minutes
on average to deal with a small claims
case is a highly efficient use of time
in fact I think it would surprise most
of the people of New Hampshire that
that's all the judge time on average
that it takes for a small claims case
yeah thank you yeah thank you Mr
chairman so I mean it's possible that
technology can provide
more productivity in certain areas right
I mean maybe things you're doing by hand
could be done on computer Etc right okay
let me ask specifically about
um
the protective staff you said there was
150 officers that seemed like like a
very high number is it is it possible
that
um Capital Equipment could somehow
reduce that you know more doors that
automatically lock or something like
that yeah so just uh
great question let me just step back and
describe how we deliver security in our
courthouses
in the Superior Court
our courthouses are protected by County
sheriffs
and we the judicial branch pays
reimburses the county sheriff's for
their time in protecting those
courthouses in the circuit courts
for the most part there are some
co-located facilities we have a team of
court security officers
they are all overwhelmingly part-time
employees
they tend to be retired
um retired retirees
um we have 34 locations to to protect
roughly uh with our court security
officers we do need Capital Improvements
in in our courthouses to enhance
security and we've been able to access
actually some arpa money for that but
but you will see as part of our budget
some requests to enhance
the equipment that we need for our
officers in our courthouses but
generally we need courts security
officers at the door and ideally in the
courtroom
to to deal with court security issues we
cannot
ask judge king to correct me but
certainly in the Circuit Court
while there's a hearing going on there
is not necessarily a court security
officer
in the courtroom
I believe there is but the problem is we
don't have enough so there are days when
a judge is in a courtroom by him or
herself without security the Securities
primary responsibilities to cover the
front door but we did have a situation
within the last 12 months where a
disgruntled litigant in a family case
showed up at a courthouse with a
automatic weapon and we had about a five
minute heads up that the person was
coming and there happened to be some
State Police in the building and they're
able to secure the door but we did we
deal with very volatile situations and
chief justice Broderick used to say it's
not an issue of if something bad is
going to happen it's when is it going to
happen so security is is it and the
chief justice has been very adamant
about trying to beef up our security and
we're very grateful for that
I mean by definition
almost invariably it's a bad day if
you're coming to one of our courts no I
understand
um
unless you're unless it's an adoption or
a name change yeah okay thank you so I'm
going to ask about the part-time judges
that there was a list of six or five
um but I I I I heard that I heard that
in the past you had 29 or something and
that there was a pool of 47 so some of
these numbers didn't make sense to me so
at the time we created the Circuit Court
which was July 1st 2011 there were 45
full-time judicial officers and 29
part-time judges okay
the chief alluded to uh or maybe was
Judge Neto to turn over I'm the only
full-time judge left on the bench at the
end of this week that was a full-time
judge when we created the Circuit Court
we've had about 50 appointments to the
circuit court judge Lyons retires this
week but back in judge Hewitt's days
there were 100 part-time judges that
used to be the model we've moved away
from that it was certainly more cost
effective but we've Consolidated courts
and we've we've gone two-way full-time
judicial model and that's what we think
is best for the state
um and so we have asked the governor
actually for part-time appointments just
to try to fill the Gap because we have
funding
but there aren't folks signing up for
that we've been able to attract a couple
of retirees who had left the law
practice and were you know I kind of
twisted their arms and said don't you
want to be a judge for a few years
before you retire finally but from what
we pay them a per diem and for what I
see hourly rates of attorneys and bills
that I see these days they can make
pretty much in an hour what we would pay
them for the day and so it's not it's
really would be it's really difficult to
fill those part-time positions so I
think it's not the model that we want
going forward
are you saying you have open part-time
positions or not really uh the governor
could have there are we went we had 27
we have six the governor could certainly
make part-time appointments if he could
find someone that was willing to do the
work the problem that we have if I have
a full-time judge that's getting paid
benefits I can say you know you're
you're going to Manchester that's your
you're going to be there 249 days a year
but the per diem say you know what I
don't want to go to Manchester but I'll
sit in Concord but I only want to hear
criminal cases
and I can say either yes or no I can't
say no you're going to hear divorce
cases so the per diem judges that we
have are pretty picky about where they
sit what days of the week they sit and
what cases they'll hear and I'm grateful
for their service but I don't have a lot
of Leverage to to over them
thank you
um how is the ending of felonies first
going to affect your expenses
uh
another great question representative
those are not baked into our data at all
that was just not part of the study will
it affect the Circuit Court absolutely
can you predict it's another 8 900 cases
that will come our way on the way to
Superior Court we'll obviously take
judicial time and staff time to process
those and then they'll go to the spirit
board where they'll go through the exact
same process the bail Herring and you
know the arraignment and
Etc so it's not an efficiency it's kind
of the reverse of an efficiency
okay so I take it you're not a fan of
this well we worked very hard a few
years ago to create and actually chief
justice Nano did the work but we agreed
with her and
I'll let her she she can speak to it
much more articulately than I can I'm
just sort of bracing for January 1st
because I looks like it's coming back
and we're getting ready for it we have
to I see
okay
um what um what fraction of criminal
cases are drugs the main aspect of the
case
to 80 percent
okay and if we were to legalize
marijuana as a recreational drug would
that make it much of a difference
well you know I think in both courts uh
it's okay chief if I answered try to
answer it yeah please oh I think
I think for the Superior Court it
wouldn't make much of a difference it's
it's mostly fentanyl heroin cocaine
methamphetamine things like that
assuming a static
situation I mean
if if one drug was became legal that
might take demand more or less off of
other drugs right so I think there was a
study in Colorado that proved that not
to be true so I should take a look at
that again okay
um
I think that's been more than three
thank you
are there any other members of the
division that have any questions while
we take a short question break
seeing none uh oh I'm sorry
representing evil
thank you very much for coming I was I
was trying to figure out
um what's the how do you I'm trying to
get a handle on the Staffing shortfall
due to budgetary concerns versus just
the general difficulty of attracting
folks
it's it's an excellent question
um we have a general difficulty in
attracting folks our court assistants
make
between 14 and 15 dollars an hour we are
literally losing people to Dunkin Donuts
and McDonald's
we some of our
most customer facing public-facing
functions have some of the highest
attrition rates
to achieve efficiencies we want run for
both our trial courts in information
center
which is staffed by people who answer
calls from to deal with answer questions
about cases in both of our trial courts
there is uh I think judge king retention
or turnover rate of 60 percent among
information center two uh the entry
level position we have 70 percent
turnovers 70 percent
turnover rate
so this is not unique to the judicial
branch it's something that employers are
dealing with and certainly state
government is dealing with but to get to
your question representative
it makes no sense and you will see this
in our budget to create a position that
you cannot fill because the compensation
is not adequate and we need to address
that because it would be a pointless
exercise
follow-up
um so that's you were focusing more on
the clerical folks what about at the
judge level
there's there's no I we we I we have an
excellent
Judiciary in our state
and uh we are I'm not concerned about
the level of compensation for our judges
in terms of attracting uh quality Talent
we've had some excellent appointments uh
to the bench in both of our courts so
that's not a concern representative
yes we are very lucky we have very
dedicated judicial branch and
representative hatch I believe has a
question
come on here about the call center if
there's a concern for retention there
um
didn't wasn't that very isn't that very
successful didn't that ease uh the
burden and for the entire court
elsewhere and so uh the lack of
retention there is that causing severe
issues for the call center and do we
need to look at waste for retention or
might be a dumb question but I I think
that concerns me hearing that it is uh
reps McGuire asked about efficiencies in
our system I would say that uh when
confirmed I was not Chief Justice at the
time but when the pandemic hit there
were a couple of Investments with the
support of the legislature that had been
made that enabled the judicial branch to
Pivot and continued to deliver its
services to the state of New Hampshire
notwithstanding the pandemic and one was
the information center which was able to
go fully remote and seamlessly continue
to answer questions from from the people
the other was investments in technology
we have electronic filing in many but
not all of our case types so that
reduces that reduce the need for for
staff and we also had
you know good investments in technology
in our courthouses But to answer your
question representative the the ability
to staff these information center
positions are absolutely critical and I
think if you ask uh practicing attorneys
or
self-represented litigants in your
District whether they've had to wait
online uh you know on the phone while
getting their call answered I think the
answer is going to be invariably yes for
a long time and that is not something
that we want that's not efficient
for our lawyers our citizens we need to
do better and that's not a function of
people not working hard it's just not
enough people answering the phones
well thank you
um so what
I mean there's obviously interest to
this I mean buying the obvious such as
pay and other things what can be done to
address the retention problem or am I
looking at something that's not as big
of a problem as it sounds to me on the
onset
um you know what I mean I said is is
providing that service uh jeopardized by
the lack of retention we we need to
address retention in the critical Factor
there is what we pay them but we're also
looking at other ways to enhance
the if you will employee experience in
the judicial branch and we are investing
very heavily in staff training which
we've heard from our staff that they
really really benefit from and really
um
desire and it makes it a more attractive
place to work just this morning we had a
two-hour branch-wide training session
where all of our employees were able to
get online and get trained on mental
illness and how we deal with our
citizens who with mental illness who
come into our courts
so retention beyond what we can do
Beyond paying them more and that's going
to be ultimately a an issue for the
legislature in this body we're also
working on
okay does that answer your question I I
see I'm just I'm just concerned that uh
if I may if there is as
big of a problem as I'll think of a
problem is it it's a big it's a big
problem so what do we need to do to
address that from our end I mean you
will see in our budget requests a
request to increase the amount that
we're paying our court assistance okay
okay thank you thank you
seeing no further questions at the
moment Mr chief justice please continue
um slide 38 will pick up and what I
wanted to do spend some time for the
benefit of the division is is address
some of the ways we're trying to be
Innovative and better serve the citizens
of New Hampshire people of New Hampshire
and I first want to start with uh our
treatment courts and a true national
leader in the development of treatment
courts is sitting to my right Justice
NATO who has led our effort with respect
to our drug courts and
invite her to to spend some time with
the division on what we're doing thank
you thank you Chief and thank you to the
members again and I also representative
Weiler he's he was with me from the
beginning so I can talk about that a
little bit but I I want to talk to you
about treatment courts in general
because it's obviously something I'm
pretty passionate about and you all the
legislature supported Statewide funding
for drug courts back in 2016. and what I
want to tell you about drug courts is
they are a way to manage a population
that we see constantly coming through
especially the Superior Court this is a
felony
program and what we would see is people
coming through the system I would see
them over and over and over and over
again and they'd just get escalating
jail and then prison sanctions and what
we try to do with treatment court is to
Target those people the people that have
severe substance use disorder not just a
first-time offender and somebody with a
lengthy felony record and instead of The
Next Step being State Prison they enter
treatment court and treatment court is a
way to combine accountability with with
treatment in the community so people can
actually learn to change the way they've
been behaving over the many years of
their lives that they've been dealing
with substance use disorder so when
somebody is in drug court they plead
guilty to the charges that are pending
it's not just drug charges it can be
burglary theft robbery anything that's
related to their to their use of drugs
they plead guilty they receive a
suspended state prison or suspended
lengthy house sentence and then four
years of probation with treatment court
and the team that gets together is the
same judge same prosecutor same defense
attorney same treatment provider same
probation officer same law enforcement
officer same case manager they all get
together every Monday or Tuesday and
they review the 20 or so cases of people
that are going to come in and talk about
how they did the prior week so somebody
in treatment court is receiving three
hours of treatment three days a week
plus individual treatment plus random
drug tests you know they have a chance
of getting called one in seven chance
every single day they call a phone line
if their color comes up they get a
random drug test they do case management
once a week they do probation check-in
visits so it's and they see the judge
every week so it's a constant high level
supervision while we teach them to
change their behavior and it's it's been
pretty successful I I love to to quote
the prior chief of Nashua who said at a
sort of a rotary Gathering once that you
know I have a hundred burglaries a year
in Nashua I know they're not committed
by 100 people they're committed by the
same 10 people and eight of them are in
your treatment court and my burglary
rate's gone down so to have a law
enforcement officer with that kind of
endorsement of treatment court and I'll
you may recall but I'll remind most of
you were on finance at the time it
passed in 2016 and it was a unanimous
vote out of Finance which is something
I've never seen before and
representative Weiler was with me when
we started one in in Rockingham County
with only Federal funding the federal
funding ran out we had to go convince
the county to please please please take
it over and continue funding which they
did and I think that was a huge reason
why the legislature saw the value of it
also Stratford county is a strong leader
in the treatment Court movement Grafton
County those are the two first-time drug
court operators so it's a really
important program it's something that
we've been growing we now have drug
courts operating in 10 of our 11 County
locations we've served over 1600 people
that doesn't sound like a lot but when
you keep in mind that these are people
that are constantly reoffending so they
they account for a lot more of the crime
than just 1600 cases they're they're
people that would be headed to the state
prison commissioner Hanks tells me that
once drug courts rolled out a couple
years later she felt like her census
went down a piece of that was the drug
court program also it you know it's hard
to tell is it helping the state
prisoners and helping the county jails
probably a little bit of both depending
on where somebody might be headed if
they didn't have an opportunity for
treatment Court we also have
um mental health courts that are
operating in in many of our counties I
think we have 16 mental health courts
many of them are in circuit court
because they're targeting a little bit
different of a population it's the same
model the same team approach the state
same response to behavior Jim Leary a
circuit court judge was somebody who
spearheaded uh the mental health court
in Nashua and he's become a model for
our state
unlike uh drug courts there are no
National mental health court standards
so recent recently judge Ashley and I
worked with a group of of prosecutors
and mental health coordinators to come
up with some New Hampshire standards
they're modeled a little bit after the
drug court standards plus there are a
couple of states that have come up with
their own so the mental health courts
are not state funded they are they're
all very different depending on what
resources a County mental health
facility has and they may be more
diversion type program they may be that
more intensive supervision program but
we are trying to sort of come up with
best standards help all those mental
health courts adjust some of their
practices as long as they have the
resources to do that so we're that's
that's sort of a new new approach and
then finally I'd love to talk about one
idea that we had in Circuit Court was a
family treatment court it's it's another
similar model people who are losing
their kids because of substance use
disorder it's a similar model where they
are responsive to the court they have um
dcyf sort of acts as the role of the
probation officer they have intensive
treatment they have a lot of monitoring
they have um help reuniting with their
children so that's a pilot project right
now and we hope that we can see how
their success pans out and maybe
duplicate that across the state and
finally one of the projects I'm really
proud of and and is funded by the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs is our community housing
program and we work in collaboration
with HHS and Doc which is really
exciting to see that sort of approach
that across agencies and branches and
what that program does is it provides
Gap and Bridge housing for people who
are in drug court or people who are
coming out of the prison and we all know
that people who don't have housing
they're more likely to reoffend relapse
even if they're getting treatment when
they have housing they have stability
they're able to continue with their with
their work and their program so the
community housing program has been in
operation for a couple of years I think
we've served over 600 people housed
maybe 400 people and the important thing
to know is it's Bridge housing we're not
just paying for people to have permanent
housing it's emergency housing it's
sober living and we have relationships
with some landlords that are actually
now understanding how treatment courts
work and have a voice in the community
and so we give somebody maybe a three
month of three months of housing until
they can get their feet on the ground
until they can get a job until they can
start paying for themselves and it's
really helped people maintain and find
housing on their own it's become a
national model actually the National
Association of drug court professionals
asked us to give a presentation on it
last year at their conference which we
did the governor is incredibly
supportive and he was really happy to
hear the presentation at a meeting that
we had last year so that's it for the
treatment Court piece I'm happy to
answer questions I also should let you
know that anytime this division or all
of Finance wants to hear more about
treatment courts I do have more sort of
comprehensive presentations also
everyone has an open invitation to go to
any drug court session in the state
they're usually Mondays or Tuesdays but
you can reach out to me and and find out
when they when they are in your counties
thank you representative McGuire
followed by representative Weiler
so I guess I'm unfamiliar with this area
you said mental health court
I'm unaware that mental health is a
crime right it's not a crime but what
happens is people with mental health
issues commit crimes and and
unfortunately you know back in the back
in the 50s with that well-intended idea
to de-institutionalize Mental Health
Services and and have them be provided
through the community those Community
Mental Health Services were not fully
funded so the jails started becoming the
mental health facilities and we the
jails are not equipped to do that so
what we're trying to do is identify
people that are constantly either
committing Criminal Trespass or their
their um some committing small minor
misdemeanor thefts or shoplifting and
it's related to their mental health we
want to give them an option to stay out
of the jails to stop recycling through
the jails and work with a treatment
provider sometimes it's as simple as the
person who's committed the crime doesn't
realize they are eligible for Medicaid
and it's just that connection with the
men the Community Mental Health provider
that gets them out of the system so so
that's why we have these but you're
right I don't want to build it so they
will come come that is the last thing I
want to do so so
the the money spent on treatment and
housing Etc that's not from the
Judiciary budget right that's from HHS
or wherever right when we're talking
about the mental health kind of docket
if somebody's got mental health issues
they are getting Services through their
Community Mental Health provider and
they're either paid for by Medicaid or
bdas is providing
um that it's not judicial branch the
drug courts we are sort of the
repository for the funding and then we
contract with a treatment provider who
provides treatment services for people
who are in drug court and we it's not
part of this presentation because it's
not part of our way to caseload study
but we will probably ask for an increase
in funding for the treatment courts
because we haven't seen one since 2016
and and we're kind of losing providers
because they aren't able to maintain a
living based on what we can pay them but
that's a that's for our major budget
presentation
representative Weiler
thank you Mr chairman thank you chief
justice NATO I was very impressed with
drug court when you came to Rockingham
County and asked us to demonstrate and
then
you should all try to go to a Drug Court
graduation
very impressive uh you listen to the
history of these people they've always
been on the underclass they've always
been on the bottom and then they come to
graduation the prosecutor gets up and
talks about their how wonderful they did
the the counselor the the uh the manager
and of course the judge gets up and says
what a good person they were had become
and and as I left it I thought about
some of these people
unfortunately this might have been the
first time in their lives that someone
gave them compliments from an official
standpoint and I thought this positive
reinforcement great idea and you know I
think probably that's why we were so
impressed with it in Rockingham County
and it went on to the rest of the state
so thank you for creating that well
thank you for keeping it going
very well said representative Weiler
thank you
any further questions on this little yes
go ahead this is all very exciting and
I'm so pleased to hear about all the
success could you explain the interplay
between the mental health treatment
court and the drug court because I would
expect there are people that yes use
drugs that have mental health yes the
people in our drug courts 80 percent of
them have co-occurring disorders so they
may have anxiety depression even bipolar
all untreated PTSD many of them have
trauma so there is an overlap and what
we try to do is we try to look at what
is the what is the major glaring
component sometimes someone starts off
in mental health court and we realize
they actually need drug court because
um the it's the drugs that are creating
this problem for them and vice versa so
there's definitely overlap and there are
risk assessment tools that we use to
assess each person before they enter
into a program that gives us a better
idea it's an objective evidence-based
study tool that tells us what's their
score in terms of mental health issues
drug drug abuse issues and criminal
thinking and that helps us Target where
they should go
and the judges at these courts are
superior court judges in drug court
they're all superior court because it's
a felony drug court program and the idea
is to Target that high-risk high-ended
person that we see headed to State
Prison as their next step the mental
health courts sometimes they are
diversion programs and they don't
necessarily need to see a judge that's
another piece we're trying to figure out
that the Circuit Court does not have the
resources to have a judge be meeting
with people every week and so we need to
figure out whether or not how we want
that model to look but diversion is is a
possible model that works for mental
health support
and that's the same with the family the
family and we have only one family
treatment Court that's in circuit court
because it's it's parents who have been
found abusive or neglectful of their
children and we want to reunite them by
making sure their substance use is
addressed
all right thanks so much I just uh
continue on on page 47 want to pick up
on the theme of mental illness uh New
Hampshire is not immune to uh just as
NATO alluded to this is not immune to
the phenomenon that people end up in our
courts solely for the reasons that they
have under treated or untreated mental
illness
and they cycle through our system
they are repeat offenders
and that the consequences of that or
they end up in a county jail or state
prison which is not clinically
appropriate for dealing with mental
illness I mean they do the best they can
but it is extremely expensive place and
and we need to get these people the care
they need before they enter our system
uh this has been the subject of a major
uh initiative by something called the
conference of Chief justices which is
comprised of all the chief justice state
chief justices around the country
and came up with a task force report
after three years
um in July and our
Judiciary is committed to doing our part
in trying to address this problem
to identify opportunities for our people
to avoid the justice system to get the
services they need so they do not enter
into our system and thereby enhancing
Public Safety
providing critical services for the
people who need it and also saving the
taxpayers money
and so Diane Martin the AOC director is
really leading our effort and maybe just
talk a little bit about sequential
intercept mapping sure so um as the
Chiefs both of the Chiefs uh have said
mental illness is obviously
um something that is seen in the courts
on a daily basis and so a national
judicial task force looked at this issue
and came out with a number of
recommendations in October of 2022 one
of the recommendations
excuse me was that
um court-led initiatives in States tend
to be more successful in bringing Focus
to issues and so they recommended that
the courts lead collaborative efforts
within their states to help address
these issues and one of the
recommendations that they had was that
sequential intercept mapping which is
really getting together with the
stakeholders throughout the state
looking at what resources are available
looking at what best practices are
already being done and identifying gaps
and then using all of that information
across the state to improve how we serve
those experiencing mental illness and so
we at the court are are leading that
initiative we applied for a grant from
the state Justice Institute and got some
Grant funds to move forward we're
conducting a survey internally to see
how we can improve our responses to
people coming into the court and this is
beyond just
um
in in the courtrooms but our court staff
and our judges and how we can do better
there and we are also moving forward
with sequential intercept mapping across
the state the first of those will be
with Merrimack County they actually had
a small group of judges and stakeholders
already convening who are really
interested in doing better in this area
and so they volunteered to be the first
group so that sequential intercept
mapping
is planned for April of this year it's a
two-day event where your county folks
will come together with your court
people your mental health centers all of
the individuals who touch on people who
are experiencing mental illness and
really work to identify what resources
we have to address that and what we
don't and try to come up with a plan to
do better so we're really excited about
that after we get through the first one
the plan is to do that Statewide
um
over probably the next couple of years
thank you the next uh area I want to
talk about is uh let me identify the
issue first and then talk about how
we're addressing it
um any day in one of uh the circuit
court houses
um 90 or more of the litigants appear
without an attorney
and they're in as you heard the types of
cases that are in Circuit Court are very
immediate and very directly affect the
lives of the people involved
so they are there on a perhaps an
eviction action a landlord tenant action
small claims uh divorce and parenting
domestic violence all of these really
immediate potentially life-changing
issues without an attorney
it's a very big and very complex problem
but it's very important to us that we do
the best we can as a Judiciary to try
and alleviate the consequences of what
we call the access to Justice gap which
is the the problem caused by up to 90 or
more of litigants not having an attorney
um so on page
52 last year the legislature enacted a
an important bill that I was pleased to
support which is to have a a pilot
program which authorizes
paraprofessionals to appear on behalf of
clients in three of our circuit courts
it's it's an experiment really and the
three circuit courts of Berlin uh
Manchester and Franklin uh so that's
ongoing and it was an important
initiative this legislature and we're
going to take the data and the results
of that and report it back and see if
it's it's an idea that should be
expanded Statewide
uh next I want to invite judge king up
here and talk about some of our efforts
in in landlord tenant
so landlord tenant is a is a pretty big
part of what we do we had sort of a
Hiatus during covid because the there
were a number of
um sort of holds put on landlord tenants
through the by the federal government
through that process but we're back up
and running now and mediation has been
very successful in those cases where
landlords and tenants are able to get
together and there's a as you all well
know a very uh big shortage of housing
in New Hampshire and so when someone's
fortunate enough to be
in a housing situation
um getting evicted means that they may
be without a place to live so and the
landlords don't necessarily like
turnover either because it's expensive
for them they have to clean the
apartment find somebody else and go
through the whole process so uh the
mediation has actually been very
successful and now we have started we
were actually one of the first states in
the country to start
um eviction diversion which is a process
that before the landlord decides to
evict someone we offer mediation uh to
try to avoid that eviction action from
ever being filed and it can be working
out a payment plan to get them caught up
whatever the issue might be and we've
received Federal funding to continue
that program through a grant and we
think we may reach as many as 1100
landlord tenant disputes pre-filing uh
in a year to hopefully allow the people
to stay in their housing and figure out
how the landlord can continue to get
paid so it's a it's kind of a New
Concept the statute allows us to do
mediation in cases where there isn't a
case yet and we're really optimistic
that that's going to be a benefit to
both landlords and tenants
just another example of our efforts in
this area page 55 or state law library
as part of the judicial branch and and
one of the challenges that our
self-represented litigants face is just
access to basic legal materials the
stuff that lawyers use in preparing
cases and arguing before judges and so
our law library has been working with
our public libraries around the state to
provide access to something called
Westlaw Westlaw is one of the two major
legal databases and so if you go to a uh
our public libraries in Dairy Portsmouth
and Littleton you have free access to to
Westlaw and that's been an important
resource for a self-represented
litigants and just recently uh the clip
you have on page 55 is
actually Monday's paper where we
announced that we're making Westlaw
available to people in their homes if
you sign up
or wherever they are they don't have to
go to the public library and that's
another resource that we're making
available to self-representative
litigants and of course they can come
into our state law library and access
our resources there
then finally this is really important to
me since I became Chief just to say I I
really believe strongly that as the
judicial branch we're sort of isolated
and it's it's a function of what we do
but
we there are lots of opportunities for
us to engage with our communities and
and get out there and educate them on
what we do and
what the rule of law is and how our
system works and we've got a really some
very important programs with respect to
Civics education and judges actually
reaching out we have something called
national uh judicial Outreach coming up
in March and our judges along with
attorneys are deploying across the state
to to meet with Community groups Mr
chairman I'll report that I will be in
your neck of the woods presenting at
Conan High School in in Jaffrey Middle
School uh within a with the lawyer and
really excited to meet with students
there in addition the Supreme Court has
regular on the road sessions where we
actually take our court session to a
high school earlier last year last fall
we're up in Whitefield at White
Mountains Regional High School really
great session so we're trying to promote
that and certainly if any groups in your
community
want to hear from us I I love to do this
and uh and it's it's
really rewarding to get out there and
meet with our people our state and talk
about what we do
so with that Mr chairman respectfully
submitted
uh thanks so much and
I guess are there any further questions
uh if they're not I've of course oh
thank you having been involved with two
of these people in 2011 in court reform
and having known the chief justice for a
number of years and seeing him at the
Attorney General's office
I'd like to compliment them all because
these are people although many of the
Departments we deal with it's all hey
we're important just give us all the
money these people are are Partners in
trying to make everything more efficient
and better
and I've always been impressed with all
of them especially from some of the
previous Chief justices that we had that
hey don't tell me what to do you know um
these people are willing Partners In
keeping this budget down and I want to
thank them for that and also mention to
this committee this is a new unique
thing
most of the other departments we see
will have come through the
administrative services with the
governor
because this is a separate branch of
government they don't go through that
process they just come to us for the
budget so this is the only presentation
they make dealing with the budget
strictly to us they don't come through
the filter of the executive department I
think it's important and maybe maybe
it's a better relationship I don't know
because I've always enjoyed working with
these three people I think they're rock
stars are keeping this system growing
great I want to thank you all for this
presentation and the work you do thank
you so much Mr chairman that means a
great deal to us thank you thanks
representative Weiland and just to add
to that I think this is my eighth term
on division one and after hearing from
the judicial branch I always feel like
we're in really good hands in the state
I I just have this confidence that and
maybe some is representative Wireless
said at other departments we may be able
to feel quite that way but there's such
a great history for what you've done in
the service to the state and I just feel
really good about it so representative
McGuire probably has a question
yes I do yeah so um you know to sort of
follow up along those lines I'm this
term I'm a prime sponsor of a bill to do
some reform under on the asset
forfeiture area with the idea of
streamlining the process a bit are there
other things
um that are in the law that
cause you
frustration that that you know if only I
didn't have to fill out this form or if
only I didn't have to you know do those
things so things that we could change
well I mean there is a bill right now
and I think it's in the Senate on the
medical malpractice panel so I don't
know if you've heard about that that it
was a well-intended process that was set
up as sort of tort reform and required
all medical malpractice cases to go
through this panel process first before
they could come to court and we've we
are working on either pausing it and
studying it more or eliminating it
because it actually we've seen over time
maybe we have an average of 75 medical
malpractice cases filed per year and
zero to two of them end up going to to
panel because they can wave it if they
want to so that's that would streamline
it takes a one and a half full-time
employees to deal with the scheduling
and the collecting of information and
getting the panels together and managing
the discovery and all that so that's one
small one may I ask so are you saying
the panels should be used more that they
should not be waived or eliminated oh
just the limit I see okay because it's
the parties that wave it so they
obviously are not using it fully
that's just one example big investment
low yield yeah yeah okay not enough
juice for the squeezed or something
yeah
any other ideas or
question
um chairman Leachman about we we do
there's a separate bill for the land use
docket judge so we that that counts for
this one that we're talking about here
but it doesn't account for any of the
staff and that bill we will also ask for
a monitor and a case processor if it
passes so we would still even if that
passes asked for the four clerical staff
and one because that that's totally
separate from the land use docket
thank you uh representative Lynn is
working very hard on that so I'll make
sure I Circle back with you yeah thank
you uh representative Hewitt
yeah I just
um I just want to add a point that uh
going back to the beginning of the
presentation uh we heard a lot about the
study that has been done in the net in
the Nationwide study that was done in
the in the the fact that the New
Hampshire courts have used the process
of studying these these items to make
sure that they had an accurate figure
when you we have all kinds of people
that come to us and they're all
everybody comes here looking for money I
mean there's no question about that but
they have ideas about how how much they
should have and why
uh but not many times do you do you get
the uh
direct information as a result of other
places having accomplished a study
that's that's that fortifies the
position that the people that are before
us uh are asking for so I think we have
to be cognizant of that when we when we
deal with a budget such as the court
system because as uh representative
Wilder and the representative of the
policemen have said uh this is an
independent part of the state government
and
a lot of the a lot of the stuff that we
hear through many of the agencies that
come before us is is not something that
the the court system has any any not in
not only do they have anything to do
with it
um but they don't they don't they aren't
allowed to get involved in it so I think
we have to bear that in mind you know
when they for example when they say they
haven't got enough help
if I if I was in the position I would
tell you that no they don't have enough
help they didn't have enough help when I
was there and they still haven't got
enough help and the pro and the problem
is that people like us here in this room
don't recognize uh that their problem is
kind of different
from a lot of the problems we hear even
in the case of uh adding adding the
adding money to salaries you know we
don't we don't realize that they're in
the same boat as everybody else
thank you
thanks for your comments are there any
further questions representative evil
to keep up with representative McGuire
um could you speak a little bit about
the effect of the retirement age
requirement on keeping your
judge numbers up good question
um
there may be differences of opinion I
mean I
we we don't
um
we've got a very strong bench and
attracting quality candidates to serve
in the Judiciary has not been a problem
for us in my opinion
um
I I will be completely transparent about
this I I think that turnover in any
institution is a good idea and
um I
you know I I certainly don't subscribe
to the idea that one can't
successfully serve beyond the age of 70
but I do think that having regular
turnover particularly in an isolated
institution like the Judiciary is a good
idea and and
the age limit is sort of a
built-in term limit if you will that's
my but that's solely my personal view
that's Gordon McDonald
sure my my comment is actually kind of
the reverse of that at least as
much as I represent the circuit court
and it's trying to keep the judges from
burning out I don't think most of the
Circuit Court judges are retiring when
they're able and I don't think if you
change the Constitution I don't think
you'd find many takers that could keep
doing it I mean I worry we've had a lot
of great appointments as the chief said
some of these judges are very young I'm
wondering if they're going to be able to
keep up with the pace for the 25 years
it's going to take them to get to their
eligibility and I'm I say that in all
sincerity it's
uh It's a Grind and I worry about them
burning out and having their own sort of
mental health issues keeping up with the
nature of the cases that we deal with
the volume
um and so I I'm not sure it would make
much it certainly wouldn't make much of
a difference for the judges that work in
the Circuit Court I don't think I agree
with that
thanks very much for your candor
any other
questions
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the division it's an honor to be here
foreign
all right thank you very much I
apologize for our uh delays and I'd like
to welcome uh members of the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services oh here we go
foreign
welcome commissioner and your staff
thank you uh Mr chair I thought it was
just you you wanted to make a grand
entrance and that was very dramatic I
try to avoid those so uh welcome good
afternoon everybody uh members of the
committee and Mr chair
um my name is Bob Scott I'm a
commissioner of the Department of
Environmental Services thank you for uh
inviting us to uh
talk a little bit about what we do we're
always happy to talk about our our
mission and our different programs uh so
first I'd like to to introduce some of
my key staff here uh so I have uh to my
right is probably one of the I'll brag a
little bit probably one of the uh she's
our chief operating officer and and I
would argue one of the the certainly a
jewel for the state as far as
understanding the process for uh moving
money and our agency does a lot of that
so we're really happy to have Sue
Carlson with us as our chief operating
officer uh in the background I think
he's still there yes is our assistant
commissioner Mark Sanborn
and then you'll hear individually from
our three division directors so our as
long as it works for the the committee
and the chair uh I was going to talk a
little bit about generically what we do
uh on the grand scale and then have our
division directors speak no more than 15
minutes that means you Mr Pelletier
uh that uh is uh on their programs and
certainly probably the most important
thing is to make sure we can answer any
questions you have and we want to leave
time time for that so again as I alluded
to so we have three division directors
uh Rennie Pelletier is our Water
Division director uh he'll be up in a in
a little bit uh we'll start with our air
Resources Division uh Craig Wright
uh and then uh last but certainly not
least is going to be uh Mike wimsat with
our Waste Management division so
um and again uh will Mr chair I don't
know if you want to wait till questions
at the end or just as they come up so
just please please uh whatever your
desire is let us know we're pretty
unruly but we take questions as we move
along make it easier to keep track that
sounds fine certainly so our we are very
fortunate in a lot of ways we have uh I
think our mission statement is uh very
helpful in US attracting and keeping
people so protecting Public Health in
the environment uh while keeping an eye
on the economy is is certainly uh you
know that makes life a little bit easier
for us to attract people because I think
that's one of the the best missions that
we have compared to others but I I am
biased uh if you go to slide three in
the handouts um
you'll see how our our department is
laid out uh we have uh three divisions
and then of course the uh the
commissioner's office which uh is kind
of a mini Division and within that we
have some things that may not be obvious
to people haven't dealt with us before
we have things like the the state
Geological Survey
um are are within that uh function in a
in a we do our internal planning but
also we have our public information
officer office is located there also and
that's increasingly uh important
um
within that uh again you'll hear
individually from the the divisions on
what they do uh roughly I think at the
moment we have on the order of 486 ftes
full-time employees 491 excuse me I've
been corrected
um our core functions as as many of you
know uh in in some of our priorities at
the moment are water quality uh
uh Water Resource Management so whether
that's storm water runoff or or or
contamination issues uh you'll you'll
hear about regulation of air pollution
um and certainly land use uh in general
materials management waste management
issues are are really uh in how we deal
with those including emergency response
UH responsibilities that we have those
are all very important we are unique uh
talking at a high level we we own and
operate you'll hear this probably from
any a Wastewater Treatment Facility in
Franklin I think we're unique in the
country uh for that as an agency we have
offices in um on the Seacoast as well
um so we'll hear about some of those
things that we that may not be as
obvious to some some that are more based
and conquered uh moving to slide five uh
of late uh I'll tell you some of our
priorities are our water infrastructure
Wastewater infrastructure there's
there's uh you'll see a mismatch of uh
acronyms uh we're lucky to have
different funding sources in the state
I've been in the state 26 years now and
usually we have problems but not a lot
of money to address it and now we're
actually have some resources to start to
address some of these problems so one is
the drinking water groundwater trust
fund uh that's uh as the name applies uh
we've been able to use that and we
allocate I'm one of the Commissioners on
the trust fund uh roughly 20 million
dollars a year towards drinking water
projects and Source water protection uh
the the state revolving Loan Fund has
been a long-standing program with with
Federal Federal funding uh we have a
state revolving uh Loan program for both
drinking water and clean water for those
those who aren't as uh immersed if you
will in our our world when we say clean
water uh in this context we're not
talking drinking water we're talking
Wastewater storm water things that we'd
like to become clean so that's that's
kind of not an obvious thing for for the
lay public and then uh arpa we've done
very well with arpa uh out of the state
and government side of arpa we've been
allocated 185 million dollars for
drinking water projects Wastewater
projects uh and uh dams uh thank you uh
so that's unique and then while I'm
talking about funding sources uh on top
of that the infrastructure bill from
from Congress uh is pumping over the
next five years a lot of money into the
srf program so that's opening up a lot
of opportunities and then an unknown uh
they'll expect there'll be some things
we'll be able to do is the the inflation
reduction act the IRA act uh I guess
that's redundant
um
we think there'll be funds available for
the state agencies also uh but but as as
yet we're still waiting for the federal
government to decide what the programs
look like what the eligibility looks
like and how we apply so there's more
coming we think uh it's less on
infrastructure that we believe will
focus a lot on resiliency uh perhaps in
in flood zones uh and environmental
justice is also something they're
strongly focusing on
um as as you're aware and you'll hear
from Mike wimsat I'm sure we spent a lot
of time with emerging contaminants and
someday I'd like to have a discussion
without using the four-letter word or
the pfas but I don't think that time is
now
uh and then within that we we're
spending a lot of time and effort to
make sure our our internal processes but
also our publicly facing processes for
permitting and just environmental data
are accessible to the public and you
know we realize there's a lot of
efficiencies to be gained there and
we're working on that also so then uh
moving to slide uh six uh on before we
go to the air division uh we've given
that you're the finance committee we
wanted to at least give you some
highlights of of the budget in fact I'm
going to put Sue Carlson on this spot
why don't you talk to the rest of these
on the budget since you're you're a guru
that's that's an official word I use
thank you Bob
um just for the record my name is Susan
Carlson with the Department of
Environmental Services
um I just put together three short
slides of where we stand
um right now in our request on the
efficiency budget for 24 to give you an
idea of the size of our agency
so that when the divisions talk about it
you can understand what we're talking
about right now our initial request
before the governor is 271 million
dollars for 24 and slightly larger
amount for 25 we're looking at
491 authorized full-time positions
we do a lot of Permitting work
we do over 21 000 permits a year we do a
number of inspections we deal with over
35 state laws and we do manage over 115
federal grants and if you turn to slide
seven what I did was give view a very
high level overview of where our funding
comes from over 68 percent of our
funding comes from other sources which
is permits fees and other funds our
general fund appropriation is only six
percent of our operating budget
currently and federal funds make up the
balance of 70 million dollars which is
approximately 26 percent how do we
actually use that money
um
our operating expenses are our small
piece
of only five percent our salary and
benefit costs are actually only a
quarter of our operating budget over 68
of our entire budget we put out the door
in terms of Grants loans reimbursements
and contracts so you see the majority of
our money does not stay within the
department it goes out to the
municipalities and other entities
Bob
sure okay
um one last slide that I put together
um is more informational because a lot
of people ask us what the difference is
between the srf programs and our grant
programs
but the state revolving Loan program is
primarily a loan program
it is loans it is based on federal laws
and regulations and the source of funds
is either federal grants to us or loan
repayments the timing of our assistance
is up front which means if you apply for
a loan you get the money and what is
qualifying entities are waste water and
drinking water treatment systems which
could be municipalities or in case of
drinking water systems small private
Water Systems are in a budget for these
loans run between 100 and 120 million
dollars
the drinky water groundwater trust fund
is an example of some of the um
the grants that we put out it is a
combination of Grants and some loans
primarily in the pfas area that is based
on State Statute this particular fund is
funded from a lawsuit again it's an
upfront and it is only for drinking
water systems
and we run between 30 and 40 million
dollars a year
um the state 8 grant program is a
general fund program
it is run it is mandated by statutes it
is what we call an after-the-fact
assistance which means you come this
communities come in for this grant after
they have built their wastewater
treatment system and after they've had a
year of operation then they apply for
this grant and we pay approximately 20
percent of their annual Debt Service
payment so when we make these grants
oftentimes we are looking at a 20-year
commitment right now our annual budget
for this program runs between 13 and 16
million dollars a year
foreign
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so on the dwdg
lawsuit proceeds is that is that going
to run out at some point or is it yeah
the groundwater drinking water
groundwater trust fund
um right now has an estimated
around
2041.
and that's based on the current spend
rate right the 30 to 40 million a year
kind of thing right because some of it
is loan some of it is Grants and the
loans will get repaid which will run
this out but as um we're actually doing
a presentation before the advisory
committee on the February 13th to give
them a status update on the forecast and
then the first two categories are there
no General funds including
salaries of the people who administer
these programs for the srf program and
the trust yes for the trust no there are
no General funds although
in the pfas program we were given a
separate 25 million dollar appropriation
just for Grants not for some the srf
program
in the Clean Water side we have a four
percent match which is State funds
and on the drinking water side excuse me
let me back up on the srf programs it is
an 80 20 grant program we have 80
percent federal funds 20 State funds we
actually provide the match for the base
Grant through the capital budget
um but on the clean water side we are
only allowed to use four percent for
administrative cost on the clean water
side
um what they refer to as semicides is 69
loans 31
um for technical assistance
Administration
so there is some general fund in this
but once we um and only on the Federal
grant side of the house
um on the repayment side of the house
that is all
um non-general fund money
thank you
representative evil thank you so in the
drinking water groundwater trust fund
that's um is that what are the sources
of funds there is that MTB
mtbe is a separate pool of money
um this
we received two pools of money from the
lawsuit
one was the settlement money
um which was approximately 81 million
dollars which we refer to as the mtbe
and that goes strictly for mtbe
remediation
um the lawsuit against Exxon is what
created the trust
and that money is what we use
um for the drinking water trust grants
that we give out
and and where is the 25 million for pfas
that sits in its own pfas fund
we have a number of
different funds
in different pots of money
and I use the drinking one to
groundwater trust as a prime example
okay thank you so if there's no more
budget related questions which we
definitely want Sue she's not going far
so uh I'll uh I'll bring up our director
right to talk about the air division
uh thank you commissioner
uh Mr chair members of the committee
pleasure to be here
uh the air division starts on page 10.
um I'll just kick us off with two
high-level thoughts about the air
division
the air division is responsible for
implementing nine State statutes and we
also implement the vast majority of
federal Clean Air Act Amendments of
1990. the other high level uh thought
I'll leave you with is EPA under the ACT
is responsible for setting what we call
National ambient air quality standards
which are health-based standards for six
criteria pollutants and it's the
division's responsibility to implement
its program monitor air quality and to
implement programs to make sure that we
meet those health-based standards
organizationally on slide 11 we have
three Bros and a director's office I
want to talk about each Bureau so I
won't mention about them right here I'll
just note that we have 65 staff highly
professional
um highly technical staff working for
the division the director's office is
obviously responsible for management
budgeting and also we do do some
technical work in the division one thing
we know and at the director's office
level is that air pollution Knows No
geopolitical Boundaries so we have to
deal with the transport of air pollution
and the director's office handles that
permitting environmental health group is
responsible for issuing federal and
state air quality permits I like to
mention the federal side because I think
it's important to know if you need an
app permit in New Hampshire you simply
come to Des you don't go to have to go
you don't have to go to EPA EPA does
have a role in reviewing our area
permits they comment and on a very small
subset of permits they have the ability
to veto a permit that but that's only
for a small subset of our sources
the purpose of the permit program is to
ensure that sources can comply with both
state and federal air regulations the
division has 40 something sets of
administrative rules and we've adopted
hundreds of federal standards for this
ease of sources being able to again have
a single permit that covers everything
they need to do on the state and federal
level
we also have a state air toxics program
where we set health-based standards for
over 600 stadia toxics there's also a
federal air toxics program known as
hazardous air pollutants we also
Implement that that is not a
health-based program that is a
technology-based program our
Environmental Health Group helps not
only the air division but also the waste
Division and the Water Division
evaluating Health impacts from
environmental contaminants and also risk
communication to communities
on the next slide slide 13 is just some
stats from the air permit program we
have 805 permanent sources in New
Hampshire I won't run through the list
you can see the different types of
permits we issue I will just indicate of
those 805 sources over 500 of them are
able to handle their permitting online
we'd like to get to a hundred percent of
all of our sources online and we're
slowly working towards that
Below on that table is just some
permanent statistics for FY their
calendar calendar year 2022 and I think
you can see as we get permanent
applications in we get permits out the
door of course following a public
process including an opportunity for
public hearing on all of our permits so
I have a quick question since I see the
bow coal plant in one of your slides
sure is here
so as you know New Hampshire another New
England states have an issue with power
supply I've noticed a bold plant's been
quite active over the last couple of
weeks are they under any sort of
restrictions as far as time frame that
they can continue to run or
what do they still have a permit that
will say go out 10 years or five years
so they are what we call a Title Five
Source they're a major federal Source uh
their permit is an operating permit that
lasts for five years and they have to
renew it on a five-year cycle
do you know what that cycle is is it are
they in the I believe they're in their
first or second year of their latest
renewed permit okay
okay questions
no thanks uh next is our compliance
Bureau this is really a boots on the
ground uh program these are the folks
out in the field doing stack testing and
compliance inspection the picture you
see here is actually one of my guys up
on a stack where we're doing emissions
testing on that particular Source we
witnessed 40 to 50 emission tests per
year those tests are done under EPA
methods generally a third party comes in
to do the testing but Des is on site to
observe the testing to ensure that it's
done correctly under the federal
standards and state standards in
addition we have 24 what we call
continuous submission monitors out there
we're on site to verify those devices
are accurately collecting data and
Reporting data so that we can monitor
air pollution from those sources
as I mentioned the compliance Bureau
also does inspections we conduct
somewhere between 60 and 80 inspections
a year we negotiate an annual inspection
plan with EPA EPA dictates that we
inspect certain sources on a in a
schedule that they set and we have to
make sure we meet that schedule under
our work plan
uh we also respond to about 80 to 100
complaints a year generally those are
neighbor on neighbor type complaints or
somebody living next to a factory
worried about odors or visible emissions
uh the other thing we do a lot of
Investigation of is illegal burning I
like the joke open burning in New
Hampshire it's kind of a beer drinking
sport that people like to burn
everything and anything we usually get
mainly referrals from local fire
departments when they find those types
of situations
enforcement's not our first tool from
compliance standpoint but we do have to
to use tools there under both this
department has an enforcement policy and
EPA also has certain employment policies
our goal is to handle all those
Enforcement cases in state not get EPA
involved other than just from a review
standpoint and a lot you can see the
statistics last year we had 38
Enforcement cases without Federal over
filing
the compliance Bureau also on slide 16 I
think has a asbestos management section
this largely is construction demo
Renault demolition renovation of pro of
projects uh we receive over 1200
notifications a year about asbestos
removal jobs and we get out and inspect
about 10 of those or 120 per year we
also have a worker licensing program in
this business program
our Technical Services Bureau on page 17
one of the main roles of that group is
to monitor air quality and what you see
here is a map of where we have our air
quality monitoring stations we monitor
from the top of Mount Washington
down the Connecticut River Valley across
the Southern Tier the Seacoast up the
Merrimack River Valley and also around
in Laconia around Lake Winnipesaukee
we monitor for five different pollutants
you can see there we don't monitor for
every pollutant at every station some
stations may only monitor for a single
pollutant for a scientific reason or it
may want it to for all those pollutants
we work out an annual monitoring Network
plan with EPA Technical Services Bureau
also deals with mobile sources mobile
sources continue to be the largest
source of air pollution in New Hampshire
we everybody's familiar with our onboard
diagnostics program everybody's favorite
check engine light program uh that is as
at least partially an environmental
program Department of Safety runs that
program what we do is we analyze the
data that they collect and then report
that data to EPA we also handle some
federal grants under the uh sorry we
handle different grants we have the
Volkswagen Grant which I'll talk about
in a different slide but we also have
Dara grants diesel emission reduction
grants
um these are this is a federal program
we match that program with the VW funds
to get bonus funds in that program this
year we have about 1.2 million dollars
in that program for to replace help
replace diesel engines
we also have a New Hampshire Clean
Cities program it's a federal doe
program we have 120 stakeholders the
goal is to help facilities and fleets
and companies to reduce Reliance on
fossil fuel in the transportation sector
page 19 uh the Volkswagen mitigation
trust folks will probably remember back
a couple years a number of years ago the
Volkswagen emissions cheating scandal
there was a national settlement on that
New Hampshire received just under 31
million dollars in October of 2017.
those funds are held in a third party
Trust Des became the lead Agency for
that for processing applications under
that trust fund in August of 2021
you can there's a New Hampshire
beneficiary mitigation plan that
dictates how we will spend that money
under the trust uh the things I'll point
out we have about 15.5 million dollars
for vehicle Replacements on the state
level and Municipal level we've
completed the state portion of that work
today 6.2 million for competitive grants
we haven't started that yet 4.6 million
dollars for installing EV electric
charging stations across the state and
we're in the process of processing 13
Grant app contracts right now to spend
that 4.6 million dollars we've processed
one or two through governor and Council
we expect to have the rest of those
contracts through this quarter
uh this says we can spend up to four
point
question I'm Sorry by representative
competitive
placing diesel it's it's largely a staff
an issue right now we only have so many
staff members to help push this money
through the goal of the mitigation trust
was to spend the funds within 10 years
the governor would wanted to get that
done in seven years I don't think we'll
quite make the seven years but we'll be
well in advance of the 10 years okay
thank you
the only thing I was going to mention uh
the 4.6 million dollars for
administrative costs that's what's
allowable under the trust we will not
spend that and we'll we'll roll
significant funds back into some of
those other pots of money
uh clean energy programs uh energies
environmental you know we all go home
turn on our lights we drive our cars uh
that's all using energy that all creates
environmental emissions we don't set
energy policy that's not our role what
we do is we serve as a technical
resource for legislative policy
commissions and we also work with the
Department of energy again as a as a
technical resource on environmental
issues related to energy and energy
consumption so this is some of the
programs listed there that we help with
uh the last slide I have is just a real
I get asked all the time what how is the
quality of air in New Hampshire and this
chart is a really nice way of showing
that uh shows our 10 counties and also a
high elevation sites which is Mount
Washington again in Pacman dad knock
generally air quality issues in New
Hampshire are ozone in the summer which
is largely an Air transport issue from
we're a downwind state but we do
contribute to Ozone levels in New
Hampshire as well and also fine
particulate matter in the winter time
which is largely somewhat of a transport
issue but also a very local issue would
uh would especially with wood burning
and Valley areas so
um the green bar the green represents
good air quality and you can see about
90 of the days we have good air quality
in New Hampshire the yellow represents
moderate air quality and we have five to
ten percent of our days reach that level
and then for a handful of days three to
five days a year we reach unhealthy for
sensitive groups that's where we're
actually exceeding those Federal
health-based standards
um I started at the division in I think
1988 back then we probably it wouldn't
be unheard of to have 25 or 30 days a
year so we've come a long way in
improving air quality our goal now is to
get that last 10 percent of the job done
and continue to maintain air quality in
New Hampshire so with that I can
certainly answer questions
for the air division representative
McGuire thank you how do these if air
quality figures compared to other New
England states
uh generally I would say this is fairly
consistent with Northern New England uh
Maine New Hampshire and Vermont probably
suffer or have generally the same air
quality Southern New England has worse
air quality in particular the
Connecticut area the Long Island Sound
and knowing in New York and New Jersey
has worse air quality
and wouldn't it yeah so I would assume
your your area doesn't use a lot of
General funds right that you you get
money from permits and and fines and
then reuse that for for staff yeah about
50 of our the year's budget is uh fees
we receive from regulated uh either
companies or entities about 30 percent
is federal funds probably
um and then the remaining percent well
actually less than that because we have
some other small accounts but we get
about half a million dollars a year in
general funds okay and is fines much of
a it's it's not a huge component
um our general fines feel like the
stationary sources the permanent sources
do not go back to the division they go
back to the state general fund the
asbestos finds under State Statute do go
back to the program okay thank you
anyone else have a question no
representative thank you Mr chair just a
quick one uh what impact did the closure
of the paper mills up north have on the
air quality standards is that uh
generally uh that paper mill was a very
significant source of air pollution
um obviously the shutdown of that
facility
um generally would result in better air
quality up north
yep
so um I can say we used to monitor up
there for certain pollutants in that
area we don't currently monitor for
those pollutants anymore because those
Mills are no longer there
and that's largely CL carbon monoxide
and sulfur dioxide I'm not sure I'm
answering your question though
I will say as a former director
if I could so even before like the uh
the pulp Mill uh in Berlin for instance
closed they had
a lot a lot of this was because of
federal requirements but they had also
uh compared to it historically they were
much cleaner than they had been even
before they closed so that's one of the
reasons why the sulfur monitoring wasn't
necessary
uh representative McGuire thank you
is asbestos winding down I mean is there
do we have a projected date when it'll
be sort of over that is a great question
I've been asking that question for years
but we steadily continue to get about
the same number of notifications year
over year we have not seen a decline in
that now some of that may be because a
number of years ago there's been a lot
of economic development in New Hampshire
so there's probably been a lot of
demolition Renovations going on but you
would expect at some point that there
would be a downturn but asbestos was
very widely used in construction
materials in the United States
thank you
thank you so now I'll introduce uh
Rainey Pelletier he's our Water Division
director and as you you'll if you didn't
know before you will know by the time
he's done this is our largest division
with the most programs
and that'll be better now that I can but
Bob's got his stun gun so I can't talk
too long
so
so as you can see with the largest
Vision within the uh the agency we
currently have some 234 people in place
we have positions that are available for
264. we've had quite a few retirements
in the last
oh several years I think last year we're
not just in the water but in the agency
like 20 or 22 people retiring people
that were clearly smarter than I am
so as we go we look at slide 23 there's
eight bureaus and programs within the
Water Division
um we we have a lot of Permitting
programs that take place and I think
we're the largest eight part of the
agency that deals with the personal
property and folks on a day-to-day basis
you know it's a lot of initiation and
concentration of how development goes
and if you go to slide 24 it talks about
the alteration of the train program and
basically the intention of that program
is any kind as a site is Disturbed
greater than a hundred thousand square
feet which is close to two and a half
acres or fifty thousand square feet
within the protected Shoreland Zone
which is zero to 250 feet on great ponds
in the State uh the whole goal of that
program is to look at pre
precipitation and post
precipitation that comes off the site of
stormwater control if you will
that's a program that you would see like
the large box stores that are built the
Home Depots the Walmarts and anything
basically that disturbs two and a half
acres of soil
if you go to slide 25 it's the
subsurface systems program a lot of
people may know that is the on-site
Wastewater disposal program we deal with
some five or six thousand permits a year
for on on-site Wastewater and it's
basically leech fields that people put
in on their individual homes and one of
the things I think that goes unnoticed
that people don't really think about is
septic systems by their design a meant
to recharge groundwater so it's a
program that's really important that the
systems are built and they're
technically designed correctly because
the ultimate goal is is to all of the
water that we use within the state
whether it be in public water or private
water is designed to go back into the
resource so it's a very important
program it's one of the few programs in
the state where the permits that we
Grant some fifty five hundred to six
thousand when they're installed we also
inspect them to make sure that they in
fact are installed appropriately so they
do in fact protect groundwater and
surface waters
if you go to slide slide 76 it's the
Shoreland program and this program
regulates activities on properties of 10
on great ponds which are 10 acres or
more from the mean lake level to 250
feet back and that in fact it's a
program that's designed to make sure
that number one
precipitation or roof drainage or any
kind of event is
adequately treated before it gets into a
surface water it's been a very effective
program in 98 it came in with a
permitting requirement and we do that's
a very active program and it's been
quite effective I think a lot of it has
a a result of why a water quality in
lakes and ponds is is continuing to be
in good shape although it's a diligent
program and we can't forget to maintain
it
slide 27
is the wetlands Bureau and one thing
about the wetlands Brewery should know
is when we issue a permit there's also
the Army Corps of Engineers looks at any
impacts to Wetlands of surface waters on
a Statewide or national basis actually
so when we issue a permit for a Wetlands
application it is also considered an
Army Corps of Engineers permit if
there's an apple an impact that's
greater than three acres then the uh
you'd have to get an individual permit
from the Army Corps which could take you
a year year and a half or two so the
benefit of us being in that programmatic
permit with the core really helps out
the applicant the citizens of New
Hampshire to move the permitting process
along it's been quite effective I think
we rarely get judged secondly on what we
permit by the Army course so it's been
pretty effective and it's really a win
for the State of New Hampshire sure
if you go to page 28 the drinking water
and groundwater Bureau
excuse me the question representative
McGuire okay this is something we were
talking about earlier my my Builder uh
told me that when he builds a septic
house with a septic system in Maine he
hires a licensed engineer they design it
it's stamped and built whereas in New
Hampshire the licensed engineer designs
the septic system but then he has to go
to the Des get another licensed engineer
to look at the same thing and prove it
again so we so the fees are much higher
here
is that so or is it uh I don't want to
say anything bad about Maine but no
there's really no fee for the inspection
you pay a one-time fee for the
application which is 300 when it comes
in now there's a cost of hiring a
designer which we license and there's a
cost obviously of hiring a licensed
installer
to install a system but there are no
other permit fees that come to the
agency so whether Maine hired someone or
not or whoever installs a system they're
going to pay somebody to install so I
don't see that it would be any different
my question is is there a second
engineer in Des
looking looking over the same design
that the first engineer created
you may need let's define the first and
second engineer you're talking about the
engineer that submits the plan yes yes
that comes in a des it is reviewed by
staff in the subsurface program and I
would very proud that our turnaround
time is one day historically and then
that goes out to the homeowner and the
designer and they hire who would they
choose to install the system okay thank
you
okay side 28 we're talking about the
drinking water and groundwater Bureau
it's one of the larger bureaus within
the division it deals with all public
water supplies we do in fact monitor
some 2600 Public Water Systems
throughout the state and those go from
the Manchester's to the nashuas or the
pennichucks of the world to uh 25 Union
or 20 unit mobile home park or
senior housing or anything on them that
magnitude and we're responsible to make
sure that their water quality is good
they sample on a monthly basis some of
the smallest systems on a quarterly
basis to make sure that in fact the
water that they're delivering to their
residents is is safe to drink they also
are a major part of the when Susan did
the funding the drinking water program
also has 75 million I think they spent
this year in apple money for the srf
program him so they they oversee a large
loan and grant program for drinking
water and much like the Wastewater
program does
so slide 29 we go over the dam Bureau we
have a two crews in the dam bureau
there's about 22 people strong we have a
construction crew and a design crew
monitor so we in fact regulate damp 274
state-owned dams that we work on there's
some
2400 to 2600 dams throughout the state
privates but the state owns 274. some of
the dams that would be notable of like
the Lakeport Dam that controls Lake
Winnipesaukee
and many of the lakes that we do
regulate are own regulated by
state-owned dams and it's a very
important function
it's a very active program especially we
have a significant storm event as you've
all seen we have to control the
discharges of those lakes and it's uh
it's really a full-time job we're
fortunate to have a really
active staff they work very hard to get
out to make sure that people Downstream
from a dam aren't getting flooded out
and those types of things and even
Upstream if you remember back some 14 or
15 years ago we had significant rain
event a lot of snow that year in Lake
Winnipesaukee was Headway speed only
because of all the boathouses the
property was getting flooded we had
people working 24 7 for quite a while to
try and control as much of that flow as
we had one thing that you want to be
aware of is dams of design first of all
in the olden days for Mills to generate
power the dams that the state now has
taken over regulate a resource for a lot
of it for recreation fishing and all the
other issues so it's really important
thing that the dam program does and it's
it's really important to how the state
gets to use a valuable resource us
whether it be boating kayaking canoeing
fishing or whatever so it's been a very
effective program in the kudos to the
dam staff
yes
probably a decade ago or less or plus or
minus the damn maintenance fund was
drying up
what's the status of that now and what
did you do to correctly
no so I should probably let uh my budget
wizard I think we did get some general
funded positions but Sue
785 000 Surplus
um we've managed through
um
using various sources to pay for the dam
repairs and maintenance
um in order to keep that fund back up
into a healthy balance well I guess that
leads to me to my question is what is
done to assure that that doesn't happen
again so are the fees for oh if I may
yeah are the fees for the dam
maintenance fund
um adequate to do that or or what what
are we doing so
um you're assured that there's adequate
funds there what resources are you
utilizing
[Music]
part of the
of the funds from water user fees so
we're trying to make an hyperfeed so
we're trying to make sure that we stay
current in all those contracts and uh
um those fees are that revenue is coming
into us we also tap into the capital
fund because a large number of this crew
is working on major Dam repair and
reconstructions and we augment that
income with Capital One so the for me
that's that brings me back to and you
hit upon it it was drying up because we
were pretty much relying on the flow
fees for uh generation and and that was
problematic so what you're doing is
using a multitude of resource funds to
address that in the fees from the flow
um
still aren't adequate to maintain that
is that not correct
and if I may would they ever be adequate
that was the original idea that didn't
seem to work too well
I don't think it will
representative evil
thank you um is there much interest in
um getting rid of dams at this point
since we have almost 2600
thank you
well you know I think there a lot of
these are one of the river dams that
have been built as you know years and
years ago and I think when there's an
opportunity depending on the ownership I
think a lot of the state-owned dams
protect the resource that's used for
recreation a lot of those types of
things but a lot of the older one of the
river dams we do take an opportunity
when the owner of that facility is
willing to work with us we try and find
several means of funding to remove them
so we can get back to fish passage and
where are you so I mean if I were to be
candid that if we could get rid of a lot
of those but a lot of them we don't own
so there's got to be a partnership and
how that's funded
and I think a lot of people have those
smaller dams and on for the big bodies
of water we talk about that have an
impoundment that they enjoy there may be
20 houses on the small impoundment and
so in many cases it's very very
difficult to get a consensus of people
that would be willing to
investigate removal
so but if we could remove them probably
the best thing for the resource would be
removal
so
yes
thank you so
are is almost all dams there for
recreation and not for reservoirs or
electric Generation Well some a lot of
the dams we have that's the fee that
representative hatch was talking about
do p pay a fee to a state-owned dam for
a hydro facility and they're Frick
regulated a lot of the other dams were
built years ago the ones that weren't
built for power and energy for Mills and
so forth are built for about
or flood control were built for
recreational persons however it wasn't
like like when a Squam or a
Winnipesaukee so a lot of people have a
lot of
vested interest in keeping those because
they if there's 20 homes on a small
empowerment they use it to kayak and
fish and so forth so
there's a multitude of uses in what dams
do
but a lot of it is generally over the
years the big ones are always for power
and the smaller ones for we're
empowerment and flood control
but not really to create drinking water
no there were some dams like pogus Bay
Winnipesaukee is an intake for Laconia
Waterworks and we do have basins up
Manchester Massachusetts that's their
water intake but the Lion's Share of
dams are not for drinking water and
they're generally uh and we try and get
people to the point where the treatment
costs are a lot less if they use ground
Waters the drinking water source so
people generally go that route first and
foremost if they don't have any luck in
achieving that then in fact they look
for surface water thank you
foreign
so if I go to slide 31 it's the last
Bureau within the department and it's
the Wastewater engineering Bureau
they're the folks that oversee all the
wastewater treatment facilities within
the state we have a very active operated
certification program as you may may not
know all Municipal in any wastewater
treatment plant has to have a certified
operator to run that facility and we
also Grant permits for the discharges
that come out of those Wastewater
facilities they generate there are a few
in the state that go to the groundwater
and generally into what we call
uh-oh I'm getting the boot and they have
a discharge to the surface water at some
point in time which we regulate as well
just to make sure that what's going into
the water resources is safe and
protected
and with that I'll the one and last
slide 33 is the Winnipesaukee River
Basin that's located in Franklin New
Hampshire as you can see on the slides
we have some 10 communities that that we
have in the state budget system but that
is totally funded by the 10 communities
that discharge waste water to that
facility we have state employees that
run that facility it was built in 1974
as you might imagine it's got a lot of
infrastructure needs and upgrades
necessary but it's been probably one of
the the only one that I'm aware of in
the country where the state owns a
treatment Wastewater Plant so it's very
unique but we've been fortunate to have
some really good staff and I think it
really has gone a long way to clean up
the Lakes Region as far as Wastewater
so with that
I'll be quiet
and just a finer point on the
Winnipesaukee River Basin the wastewater
treatment plant that that is user funded
that's not funded out of General funds
right
so thank you Randy so uh Mike you get a
whole five minutes I think you were
is uh I'd like to introduce Mike Wimsatt
with the waste management division
good afternoon again my name is Mike
Wimsatt a service director of the waste
division for the record and uh my last
name begins with W so I long ago made my
peace with going last
so I'll try I know that you've got other
folks waiting out in the lobby so I'll
try to be as brief as I can be I think
the most concise way to think of the
waste management division is we really
have two core functions one is we want
to help people and ensure that
um the materials and waste that they
generate are managed properly and then
when they when that doesn't work out we
have programs to investigate and
remediate any releases that occur
so I'm gonna I these slides I think will
speak for themselves I'm going to skip
over this in the interest of time as far
as petroleum products go that's really
the only sort of material that we
regulate the rest of the things we
regulate are either solid or hazardous
waste but we do have a very active
program for ensuring that both
underground and above ground storage
tanks are properly designed and
maintained and operated to prevent
releases of petroleum we do administer a
uh oil fund or oil discharge disposal
cleanup fund which is distributed
somewhere between 12 and 14 million
dollars a year in reimbursements for
eligible parties who have had a release
to do the investigation cleanup and
monitoring of any releases that have
occurred on the on the prevention side
for both solid and hazardous waste we
have a solid waste management Bureau and
hazardous waste management Bureau and
they perform a variety of activities
related to compliance assurance and
inspections of solid and hazardous waste
facilities facility design and review
and permitting particularly for solid
waste landfills and that sort of thing
we also track all the Hazardous Waste
shipments that occur through a federal
manifest system that's required when
hazardous waste to ship to ensure that
it gets delivered to an appropriate
facility and we also through all of our
programs maintain the ability to perform
complaint investigations when we receive
citizen complaints important to note
that we do provide the 24 7 365
emergency response capability we have
someone on call all the time and we
serve primarily we really work very
closely with local fire departments
they're the First Responders and when
they run into something where they need
our Assistance or guidance we always
have someone they can call no matter
what time a day or night that may occur
and we maintain the ability to go out
and respond and provide assistance and
also hire contractors when the need
arises
um we also do maintain a very active
program out on the Seacoast to ensure
that the petroleum products that are
stored on the piscataqua river are
managed properly and if there's and
being prepared if there's a release
primarily to protect Great Bay because
that would be sort of the big risk of a
resource out there if we were to have a
significant petroleum spill
on the cleanup investigation side of the
house I mentioned the oil discharge and
Disposal cleanup fund we also manage
about 600 hazardous waste sites and 22
Superfund sites and really the primary
way that we deal with that is we we try
to prevent exposure to contaminants
means we want to make sure when there is
a release that it's investigated
properly and assessed and then that we
make risk-based decisions about how best
to clean that up
um also it's been mentioned the drinking
one and groundwater trust fund and just
to clarify on that if there's any
confusion that was first capitalized
with two there was a 236 million dollar
trial verdict but because of uh interest
accruals and that sort of thing when all
was said and done 280 million dollars
went to that drink you want a
groundwater trust fund that was created
by the legislature uh and again that's
administered by a commission that we
work very closely with Mr Scott serves
as one of the Commissioners on that
19-member commission and to answer the
question about you know its lifespan the
commission gets an update every year on
the status of that and they make
decisions about how much they're going
to make in Grants and Loans each year
with an eye toward trying to manage that
fund as a legacy fund for many many
years to come so they can adjust that on
an annual basis about how much they're
going to make in Grants and loans and
then again as the commissioner indicated
pfas dominates the tremendous amount of
our time
um we are managing some significant
sites in Southern New Hampshire but we
do have pfas impacts across the state
and we do have a very active rebate
program for folks who want to treat
their drinking water at their home they
can put in an in-home treatment system
and apply for a rebate for to offset the
cost of that and we also administer a
pfas loan and grant program largely to
that's primarily targeted at public
drinking water systems that need to put
treatment on to make sure that the
public drinking water that they
distribute to their system meets
standards and that's a whirlwind tour of
the waste management division I'll be
happy to accept any questions
representative evil yeah um I guess I
wondered I know you know you don't want
to talk about pfas that much but as well
uh considering pfas and emerging
contaminants I wonder how money how much
strain all of the um
testing requirements all the flood of
pfas into the system how that strains
both the wastewater treatment system
landfill systems that's like a really
big soccer question but I I think it's
important to understand the effects of
all these things groundwater wise
surface water and then the strain on
Municipal and business budgets sure
thank you for the question the short
answer is is that anybody who is
involved in managing and protecting
Drinking Water waste water anything of
that sort pfas has got to be on their
list they need to be paying attention to
it we do see it in landfill leachate and
that landfill leachate gets
traditionally trucked to a Wastewater
Plant where it's you know treated and
discharged Wastewater plants currently
don't really have technology that
significantly treats pfas so it's simply
abortions at some rate between the
residuals the sludge that's created and
the discharge to the receiving body
there's really we don't the our plants
are not capable of destroying pfas in
the treatment process so we're looking
closely at that that has implications
for surface water quality but also for
how we manage residuals and biosolids
and such and then in drinking water you
know if you ask any drinking water
operator in the state he knows a lot
about pfas because they they have to
they've been even if they don't have it
above standards they've had to test for
it and determine whether it's an issue
for them and we're all watching closely
to see what EPA is going to do in
proposing a new drinking water standard
for pfas and this sometime this year we
anticipate
follow-up
so the standards that you have right now
for pfas
they're set by the state but that's
correct
could you explain how you set them do
they reflect are they tighter than other
states do they come from federal
standards I I think it's fair to say
that we have some of the most stringent
pfas standards for drinking water in in
the country there are a number of states
that are sort of aligned with us in
other states that are really haven't
found their way to that yet the way that
we set those is we we did work very
close we hired a toxicologist uh both an
internal one and we had that benefit in
the services of an external one as well
as long as as well as a team of risk
assessors who really dug into the
current science and what we knew about
it and we believe that we set a very
protective and appropriate standard as a
result of that process
having said that
um now that and that was in an
environment where EPA had not set any
enforceable standards so we were on our
own we knew we had a problem we had to
develop standards that were appropriate
and protective but right now he is kind
of catching up and they're working on
proposing we expect them sometime the
next several months to propose a
standard we don't know what that
standard will be but it is very possible
it will be lower than the standard that
we've set so to the extent that that
happens if they'll propose a national
drinking water MCL and then that won't
be effective immediately it'll go
through probably a one-year process of
finalization but once it's finalized we
would be required as a matter of say law
to to basically adopt that standard as
as the as the drinking water MCL in the
state so that's parts per trillion or
parts per quadrillion no the the current
the right currents thank you for the
question that's I believe it not an
important one
um we we currently regulate um for pfas
uh the two primary ones that most people
know about pfoa and pfos are at 12 parts
per trillion and 15 parts per trillion
respectively
um we uh and you're going down the road
the parts per quadrillion issue comes up
because EPA has set something that is
not intended to be a standard but
they've established an interim Health
advisory of four parts per quadrillion
which is three orders of magnitude lower
than where when we were talking about
before
as a potential as a zero risk Health
based number
they when at the same time we anticipate
that at the same time they set the
drinking water MCL or they propose a
drinking water MCL they will also
finalize that Health advisory and we we
think it could be we don't know what
they're going to do for exactly there's
a lot of talk around when we really
don't know but they could set it in the
quadrillion category and it's important
to understand that nobody none of the
labs in the best Labs who were doing
this work on Drinking Water Analysis can
get down to parts per quite you know
single digit parts per quadrillion
detection limits so it's a it's a cons
it's a concept but it's not something we
can really measure
Maguire thank you Mr chairman
um commissioner Scott your Des oversees
a lot of these very large trust funds
how is that money invested is it similar
to what the retirement system tries to
invest for gain or some other way
so now we're going to phone a friend
again and talk
so so uh I'll let Sue talk to that as as
far as uh working with the treasurer's
office
um yes all of our money is actually
invested by the state treasurer's office
they
um under statute have limitations on
what they can invest in and we work very
closely with them on cash flow analysis
and so that they know how much of our
funds that they can investor earn
interest
thank you I'll ask the treasurer when
they're here
that the reality of it is we are not
nearly as aggressive as the retirement
system
because by law the treasurer is bound to
limited investment opportunities thank
you are you familiar whether do you know
whether other states do the same thing
or no
I am not familiar with that okay thank
you Alice the treasury
any other questions Mr chair I know
we're running over but I just wanted to
opine a little bit on representative
Evil's question on pfas so certainly
pfas is a daunting concern Statewide and
nationally so two challenges to that and
and one I think New Hampshire has
positioned themselves very well one is
it is such a daunting concern we as you
well know we have many competing
concerns with contaminants in the
environment and what we do so it's it's
it's it's a hard hard issue to make sure
that one doesn't eclipse the other
having said that I think the good news
story is New Hampshire has done a lot of
testing sampling throughout the state so
we we understand the pfas issue uh and
now of course nobody anticipated covid
and All the Monies that are now
happening from the infrastructure Bill
and that type of thing but uh New
Hampshire is targeted to receive out of
the federal money on the order of about
10 million dollars a year for the next
five years for uh emerging contaminant
funds which doesn't have to be used just
for PFS but certainly it can I talked to
some of my counterparts in other states
and they're talking about using this
money
similar monies that they'll get to do
the sampling that we've already done and
that I feel that that's kind of
unfortunate for them because the money
needs to go to solving the problem and
remediating and that type of thing and
they'll they're totally going to miss
the whole that funding cycle which I
don't think we'll see again in certainly
in my lifetime is they're going to miss
all that because they're so far behind
the behind the curve so in a backhanded
way yes we have a problem we're not the
only ones with it and we post ourselves
very well to to make good use of the
federal money to help our communities
I just want to clarify one point though
because I'm I'm trying to link up the
how you say the pathway for pfas removal
is it true that when the say landfill
leachate goes to wastewater treatment
plants or whatever goes to wastewater
treatment plants they withdraw the pfas
and then it ends up back in the
landfills or where do the pfas or how
does that all work
in a hundred words or less if Mike
thinks he can do that 100 words or less
I guess I'm confident that I can
um the the best way to answer that is
that when the Wastewater when the
leachate containing pfas goes to a
Wastewater Plant
um it is again apportioned into two
places only one is the residuals or the
sludge that are generated from the
process or it goes out in a diluted
fashion to in the discharge to the
surface water
um depending on the plant depending on
circumstances that it's not that's not
like a we can't say exactly what that
number is what the what the percent
relative percentages are to the extent
that the sludge gets collected and then
goes back to a landfill for disposal yes
it's it's going through a cycle where it
came from the landfill and it goes back
to the landfill but not all of it
because some of it will go out in
discharge surface water discharges to
surface water
thanks
there's a hundred there's probably more
but
speed of a hundred
seeing no more questions thank you
commissioner and your staff Mike good to
see you as always and the rest of you
folks thanks for your good work we'll
see you in the next couple of weeks with
your budget
we'll just take a very short break so
the Secretary of State's office can come
in and get set up
you should have a specifically terms
well good to see you Mr secretary and uh
some former members of the finance
committee uh
and you're all welcome to come forward
if you'd like
so for those of you don't know Aaron
Hennessey served in the finance
committee and then left us went to the
Senate and now she's with the secretary
and Patty Lovejoy served as chair of
this division at one time and was on the
finance committee for a couple of terms
so we have some good friends and Dave
also we know David well so thanks Mr
secretary
you know let's just jump right in okay
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee
uh we're here to give a presentation on
the department of of State
um
I'll just start off by saying that we
are a state agency nowhere near the size
of Environmental Services but uh
but we do play an important role
um
and among the uh the things that we do
start off with the administrative
offices which is which are on the second
floor of the State House
uh an area hopefully that all of you are
familiar with but if you're not uh you
know just our door is always open stop
in
candy jars are usually pretty full so
that's handy on session days and uh you
know just out come in and help yourself
but you know in that in that uh
space we receive a lot of the statutory
required filings
from legislators members of the public
Commissioners from executive departments
we
issue a post deals which are
certifications of notary
signatures typically used for uh
foreign transactions and most commonly
those are adoptions and things like that
we
handle all of the commissions that are
approved by the government Council
related to
notary publics and justices of the peace
and there are
typically five thousand or so of those
that are issued per year and uh
Aaron knows that very well because she
has to sign every one of those so
um
the uh we also uh
cater to the governed Council so
whenever they have a government council
meeting a member of my staff is sitting
at the table keeping the minutes and and
the governor in line so
um
and so we we prepare the agendas for the
council the government Council submitted
by all of the agencies in the state
and we keep the minutes and afterwards
those minutes are put up online so that
the General Public
can hear what what happened at the
meetings
we also have a corporations Division and
the Bureau of Securities housed in the
Annex Building and I think all of you
know where that is
on the second floor
corporations of course registers all
business entities that
that are operating in the state of New
Hampshire
and the Bureau of Securities registers
dealer Brokers and those individuals
that deal with financial instruments uh
and and the General Public
so they are a the Securities is
certainly the largest revenue Source in
our office they raise in excess of 40
million dollars a year through
registration fees that go directly to
the general fund
Securities interestingly enough is
funded by the fines that they collect
through their enforcement actions
and uh in recent years they've had no
problem with the funds that they need to
operate so I think they're doing a good
job and certainly uh improving over
there
and then we have the archives building
which is up on the state hospital
grounds
um
and in that building we have the
division of Vital Records which collects
information on births deaths marriages
divorces and things like that
they um
they they take in the information they
put it in the appropriate databases and
that information then is available to
agencies like Health and Human Services
that need the information to track uh
communicable diseases and things like
that
they also share information with the
Center for Disease Control in Washington
and
um
they have a big responsibility to keep
that information the specific individual
information on the
on the individual private and
confidential and they've been doing a
very good job at that
also in the building we have state
archives which houses some of the most
precious historical documents that the
state has
um probably the most famous document is
the ratification document where New
Hampshire was the ninth state to ratify
the United States Constitution
the um
the copy that we have is better than the
one that is on display in Washington D.C
at the National Archives
uh we would like to put it on display
more but we realized or the archivists
Frank mavers when he was the state
archivist noticed that there was a
deterioration in the ink on the
parchment uh while it was on display so
it's obvious that for us to display that
document publicly for long periods of
time that it needs to be in a in an
environment that would be protected from
some light
uh and secure keep it from being stolen
um and there could be significant costs
involved with that but if this committee
is interested in coming up and viewing
it you know we're happy to make it
available for short periods of time so
that you can actually see a really
important and fascinating piece of
History
um
other documents up there civil war
records
revolutionary war records we have I
think the oldest record in the archives
dates back to I think 16 30 somewhere in
that vicinity
um
so there's a lot that you know we have
to work with there and then the records
management part of the archives is
the the vast Stacks that we have up
there to house paper copies of
correspondence and and just paper
records that agencies no longer need on
a daily basis but they haven't quite met
the retention period for being able to
destroy those records and so
we will keep those records if the agency
needs them for whatever reason they send
a request
uh we'll retrieve the information get it
to them pick it up when they're done and
refile it
and then when the retention schedule is
up on those documents we notify the
agency
ask for their permission to destroy the
records and upon that approval uh we
will we will do that
uh
through some last budget activity we
were able to create a digitization
center in the archives which has some
state-of-the-art equipment in there and
we're gearing up now to
um
use that to digitize a lot of those
important collections historical
collections that we have
but it can also be used as a resource
for smaller State agencies that want to
start digitizing their records to be
able to do that
I'm I'm I think we're very excited that
we have found a replacement for the
recently retired archivist Brian Burford
who is a young
uh a graduate dual dual Masters in
history and archives management that has
experience with archival work here in
Concord and very enthusiastic individual
that has a lot of experience with the
digitization and archives and so I think
that's going to be a huge asset for the
department and the state of New
Hampshire when we can get those records
online
um you know for the general public to be
able to access and see
[Music]
um
and then that brings us to the elections
division which is the most exciting part
of the office
it seems like we're always working in
election mode in one way or another
um
and it is probably the area that is
going to see the most action before this
committee coming up
the um
the elections office houses what we call
the help America vote act office
and that's an office that is funded by
the help America vote act which passed
Congress in
2002 uh when the Act passed it required
that the state do five things number one
create a Statewide centralized voter
database
which at the time
we did not have every community in New
Hampshire had their own
checklist of Voters some of it was kept
on paper and every time they redid the
checklist they wrote you know the whole
thing over again
and the cities had you know were more
advanced at the time and had
spreadsheets and uh computerized
checklists but we had to take all of
that information and and uh make it
uniform so that we could enter it into
the database we're currently working on
the next generation of uh we're
replacing the Legacy database that we
created that was that went into effect
in 2006 and we expect a new one to go
live this summer
with a lot more functionality so I
expect that you know the supervisors of
the checklist and the town clerks are
going to see advantages to uh what we've
created
the other one of the other things we had
to do was
have accessible voting equipment
available in every polling place so that
individuals with disabilities to the
extent possible would be able to vote
independently and privately and you know
I believe we're on our third generation
of equipment to allow that to happen and
if you go into your polling place you'll
see a white tent that's set up and
inside the tent is a printer and a
tablet
the the voter is able to make their
choices on the tablet and then when
they're ready they push the button and
an actual official ballot is placed in
the printer it goes through the printer
the printer places the marks on the
choices of the voter
and then the voter can take that and
actually run it through the ballot
counting device just like any other
voter in the polling place does so we've
come a long way in that regard
the um in the last election we had
available for the first time
uh
a a an opportunity for voters with site
disabilities to be able to receive their
ballot electronically at home
and uh in the same manner as the
accessible voting print their ballot off
with a marks on it but they would mail
it into the back into the town clerk in
the same way any absentee voter would so
uh you know we improved that process
our website went through a major
overhaul
which improves the functionality of it I
think tremendously and we're still
working on making it even better
but one of the things that we did in
that process was make the website uh Ada
accessible so that voters again with
site disabilities can pull up the
website put their cursor anywhere on the
screen and and have read to them what is
being displayed so
um that's a significant Improvement
and then we have a number of initiatives
that are ongoing
first of all you know with uh as you all
know secretary Gardner retired uh a year
ago
and uh when he left after 45 years we've
been aggressively you know going through
the department and just assessing things
and and making I think some pretty
aggressive uh improvements most of it in
the area of Technology
we
had a situation where we had inherited a
vendor that was maintaining the computer
systems
the the vendor purchased the company
from the former vendor and the new
company that we ended up with was just
incompetent
and it caused since all kinds of
problems uh you know they weren't they
weren't keeping things maintained when
we had issues whether it was in
corporations or with the Statewide voter
registration database they were very
slow to fix it they clearly didn't have
the staff on hand to handle the needs of
New Hampshire other states that had the
same company were having the same
problems so I'm happy to say that for
the most part we're completely out from
under that company now corporations the
corporation's quick start system where
agencies can honor get on and register
businesses pay their annual filing fees
is working better than it ever has been
and it allows us to look at Innovative
additions to that process which we are
doing
same is true with elections
we're looking at the next generation of
ballot counting devices because the
accuvote machine is rapidly reaching the
end of its useful lifespan and so we are
testing new models in real elections we
tested a device with open source
software during the general election and
we're testing three different devices
that have proprietary software for the
March town meeting and the towns of
Winchester Milford Londonderry and
Ashland
and so hopefully we'll have good
experiences there and I think within the
next year or so the ballot law
commission should reach the point where
they'll be able to decide which device
they want to approve moving forward
the newer technology has what's called
digital scan technology which means that
when the ballots are being fed through
the device
there is a a digital recording of every
ballot both sides of the of the paper
and so the ballot the image of the
ballast can be pulled up later which
could be really helpful in audits that
uh you know will excuse me are important
to giving voters confidence in
you know in the election itself
the use of electronic poll books is
expanding uh not as fast as I would like
to see it but we have 16 polling places
now that are using those devices and
that represents approximately 150 000
voters in the state so each each
election there's more and more of that
going on
we've expanded the training that we put
on for poll workers not only do we
travel around every county in the state
multiple times in an election cycle but
we're putting the trainings up online so
that if election officials are not able
to attend an in-person training they're
able to pull it up online and watch it
from the comfort of their own home
foreign
we've done a lot more too with voter
education and we're utilizing we've
hired a communications director in the
process which is a role that I think
would need it for a long time and that
individual has been putting up a lot of
election related information on social
media
mostly to just inform voters about
procedures in the polling place and to
encourage them to turn out and vote
we also use traditional media and we're
doing we have been doing a lot more with
speaking engagements and meeting with
groups
that are out there
um
we have done for the first time
uh
we've been working on some initiatives
with putting information out there in
foreign languages to you know the
communities in New Hampshire that don't
speak English as a foreign language and
we have populations of those individuals
that are growing So based on census
information
which we chose Spanish French and
Mandarin Chinese which in the last
census
seem to be the three most highly spoken
languages in New Hampshire other than
English
and not only have we published some
election related information in those
languages
we have an initiative in the Securities
division where we're devoting a lot more
time and resources to investor education
and we actually have a program on
investor
financial literacy
where we're trying to reach out to you
know individuals that may have money to
invest or that they want to save for
their children's college education
to know the basic language and
principles in investing and also more
importantly how to avoid scams with the
money that they want to invest and not
only did we publish that guide in
English but also in Spanish
um and I know some of you should have
received copies uh the incumbent members
the newer members will make sure that
you get copies of that so that you can
see uh that effort there's also a a web
page that goes along with that that's
interactive with the investor
and so that's an important resource and
they're also reaching out Securities is
also going out and speaking to groups
related to investor education
um
we have the campaign Finance system
which you know I think some of you have
used that has been a problem because of
the vendor situation that I had
described earlier the contract we have
with that vendor is finished in March we
have a new vendor that is ready to go so
you know the issues that we have had in
the past will not be issues for the 2024
election and
we really look forward to that
um
if there's anything else here
but there is a
a lot happening with policy decisions of
the legislature related to post-election
Audits and
the legislature prior to the 2022
election
required that the Secretary of State
conduct
audits using high-speed scanners
with two towns in the primary election
we did four towns in the general
election uh it was a very successful uh
exercise
um there's a bill in by Senator gray to
expand that uh and do it again
uh in the future
um
both Patty was very involved in that and
I'll let her speak to that in a minute
the other audit that we did was after
the election was over and and we had the
recounts there was a statute that
required us to pick
10 state representative recounts and
then do a basically another recount for
offices higher up on the ticket just to
verify the results and we did that again
a useful exercise
the legislature required that we keep
track of undervotes and over votes which
was really helpful during the recount
and the audit process because it you
know it helped
reconcile numbers a lot easier and
better than we're able to do in the past
and you know I think now that we had a
taste of doing that you know we're going
to refine the way that process worked
um
it was challenging uh you know after the
election because of the number of
recounts that we had a record number of
recounts in this last election and then
the added uh requirement of doing the
audits basically in the same time frame
and so you know we were able to get the
job done but yeah I think that we are
going to have to ask for resources in
terms of you know extra people to help
with that effort
um
and uh yeah so we'll we'll be discussing
that when those bills come before you
again this session
um in the budget we are asking for five
additional positions uh the governor
placed the positions in his budget uh
they are not specific to elections but
they are you know in the various
divisions within the department
um
you know we're trying to make the
department overall more efficient and
and streamlined and and just being being
in a better position to offer top
quality service to you know the people
that use our services uh moving forward
and I think we've come a long way in a
year and I'm really excited about you
know where we're going to be a year from
now
um uh and uh I'm gonna I'm gonna stop
there and let Patty and Aaron jump in
Aaron has been the person in the office
that has been you know working hard on
the preparation of fiscal notes you know
which are going to be important to your
committee and Patty has been
she's done a lot with the Audits and and
the recounts but more importantly she's
keeping track of
the financial record keeping that we
need to make sure that we comply with
Federal audits related to the help
America vote act and that that that
requires uh you know ongoing reporting
and we've been doing that and when
they're done if you want to ask many
questions about presidential primary I'm
happy to talk about that I won't tell
you the date that it's going to occur
but but we could talk about it so Aaron
I don't know if you want to say anything
about a fiscal note process
um
you're on the other side of that now
having to prepare it you guys are the
ones that get to see the you know the
finished product but I don't have any
comments on that uh I
can't well I'll just have to say that
it's it's much different process being
on the other side and having to respond
very timely to what I consider to be a
lot of fiscal notes but it was uh much
easier to write having been on the other
side trying to read them but if you have
any questions on them please reach out
because sometimes I don't want to throw
the LBA under the bus but they have to
take from all the different
um Department sometimes on various
different fiscal notes and consolidate
all the information so sometimes some of
what I consider important stuff kind of
gets left out so I'll I'll try and point
that out to you but
it's and I will say it's it's a
challenge for the department when there
are a lot of bills
uh that have been filed related to
elections for example that get thrown at
us in a very short time frame and some
of them are very involved so I know that
you know some of the some of the bills
fiscal notes say that this was sent to
the Department of State we haven't heard
back yet it's not because
we're ignoring it it's just because we
haven't gotten there yet you know given
the the priorities that we've been
working on with other bills so pattyland
the picture is talking about
post-election audits this was the first
time that we did them you will see other
bills coming forward for more of them uh
the one thing you need to keep in mind
is we have a very short window
elections are on Tuesday
Wednesday we go out and pick up all the
ballots
um that are for the towns that have been
selected for for doing recounts we have
to do them on Thursday because Friday is
the last day that anyone has to request
a recount
um so there's a there's a short window
the Senate uh election law yesterday
passed increasing instead of doing four
after the general election we would do
six and we think that we can still
handle handle that but it'll it's going
to be very tight
um so I know a lot of people want to do
more um post-selection audits uh but if
you want to have them done
prior to when people uh can request a
recount or just remember that very tight
friend
um the secretary also talked about the
Hava funds you know we have the help
America vote funds we have been
receiving funds at various different
iterations there's three different
um groups of Hava funds we started
getting them in the early 2000s we're
actually applying right now for the in
the latest budget that was passed by
Congress there's another tranche of
money and we're entitled to a million
dollars which we're filing for now which
we have to kind of say how we're going
to use it et cetera
there have been if you hang around in
election law at all there's a lot of
people who have ideas that they want to
change things that they want to do and
they'll always say well you can use the
Hall of funds you can use the Java funds
and you will hear that in this committee
that well there's all these Java funds
um there is a state law that requires us
to keep 12 years of the maintenance
costs basically of running our elections
and running the
um the Statewide voter registration
system Etc we do that calculation in
fact I just recently did it
um and I you know I do a three-year
rolling average I look at the cost over
the last three years and average it and
say okay we need to have 12 times that
right now
um we've got about a million one million
two maybe over and above that 12 year
um maintenance and we will be getting
this additional million but we are
spending money out of that because we're
doing that new voter registration system
so there is not it's as much as people
will like to say there's this big pile
of of half a dollars out there that
um I mean even when I was here on
division one we had multiple
bills that came forward well you could
use the Java funds for that well you
could use the Java funds for that and
and here since any of those kinds of
bills will come to division one I just
want to make you aware of the fact that
they're the hop-up funds it's not this
big pile of money that's a lot of it is
encumbered
I'll just add to what Patty said that
the the 12 times is important because it
allows uh our office to spend
right around a million dollars a year to
maintain the mandates of the federal
health America to vote act and so that
money that million dollars isn't just
free money it it actually pays for
the staff that we have up in the hub
office and I think currently we have
four or five full-time staff members up
there that are
involved with preparing the training
program for local election officials
they they maintain the uh
the the
information that is in the Statewide
database making sure that it's accurate
and you know they're constantly cleaning
it
and and then individuals that work with
the accessible voting equipment which is
actually very time consuming process
because you know you get your ballot on
on Election Day uh you you read it in
your Market you know you put it in the
The Ballot Box or the machine and that's
it but the but the accessible ballot is
a ballot that has actually read to the
voter and so though those and each
ballot is different because of the
various rotation schemes that are on it
so each individual ballot has to be
put into the system so it could be read
back to the voter it has to be proofed
have to make sure that the voice on the
machine is pronouncing the candidate's
name properly and and that's a real
challenge sometimes but but you know
these processes are a lot more involved
than they might appear on the surface
the money is used to
help pay for uh
you know improvements to the software
systems that we have as I mentioned
we're on the third generation of
accessible voting equipment
the fund pays for that and so to the
extent that
we we tap into the principle of mouth
the 12 times
and spend that down it just speeds up
the time at which we run out and then
we're going to have to go to the general
fund every time we need to work on this
program so you know the goal was the
Federal Government told us we had to do
something legislature decided to create
the the election fund so that we could
keep as much principle to earn interest
to fund the mandated programs into the
future and here we are 20 years after
the
help America boat Act was originally
passed and we still have a healthy
balance in that account that allows us
to continue to pay for those programs so
I think that's a success story and one
that we should continue
questions for the secretary or his
deputies
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr secretary for
coming I heard you say early on that
security fines pay for that department
the security fines not go to the general
fund are they kept separately somehow or
uh you know to be honest with you I
don't know how they you know I don't
think that they collect the fines and
then just spend it I think that you know
they get entered into the state
Finance system
um I don't know if they go to the
general flight I think if they lapse to
the general fund I'm pretty sure I'll
double check but I'm pretty sure they
latched to the Delta they are the
Securities is allowed to keep
uh hmm
from those funds 750 000 for its budget
I'm sure the money is in state treasurer
has that money you know it's not in a
secret account insecurities but so the
750 000 it gives them a starting point
to start off the new fiscal year and
then over the course of that you know
they collect fines that will pay for the
entire fiscal years program and then any
at the end when they're done any
money that they have has been collected
in fines above that 750 000 then lapses
to the general fund
yeah yeah continue thank you yeah this
is just a red flag for me because I'm
involved in a similar thing in the
different area anyway
um what's the retention period for
ballots
uh ballots for
for ballots that have Federal elections
on them which are our state ballots it's
22 months from the election
and that is only if there's not some
pending court case or something that you
know that requires them to be kept
longer but for state and federal ballots
it's 22 months for local ballots for
your local elections I believe it's 60
days
and towns actually like when there's a
recount related to their town because
then we pick up the ballots and we keep
them for 22 months as opposed to the
town having to keep them for 22 months I
see thank you and you use the term
electronic poll books what is that
an electronic poll book is a a device
uh
that has computer technology that
that will
it's currently choose to New Hampshire
in this way
um
it's used at the check-in station
because the entire checklist is in the
epoll book a voter can go to any
check-in station regardless of where
their name appears in the alphabet so it
speeds the line process up if a voter
has a driver's license from New
Hampshire
the machine can read the information and
populate the data that the ballot clerks
need to collect to be able to check in a
voter so that's speeds things up if the
voter doesn't does not have
a state driver's license which they're
supposed to show to prove their identity
they simply start typing in the voter's
last name and author's name is on the
checklist that's going to automatically
pop up
um and then once the polls have closed
they can simply push
a button uh and the number of the the
number of Voters who checked in shows up
like that so it saves the supervisors of
the checklist the chore of going through
each page of the checklist and Counting
the names and then finally we are
currently working on an interface
software program that will allow
the
the local election officials that have
used the knee poll book to be able to
connect with our centralized voter
database and transmit that information
in a safe and secure way so that the
supervisors of the checklist don't have
to spend hours going through the
checklist recording all the names of the
individuals that voted uh that
information will be populated very
quickly uh okay one quick follow-up so
do towns buy those from you or do you
provide them or how does that work no
the the towns are responsible for
purchasing them themselves if they want
to use them it's a local decision
whether they do it or not the ones that
are using it have found it to be a
benefit in the time savings
there is additional functionality in
those devices that could be used that
are not permitted currently in New
Hampshire for example actually voter
taking voter registrations
on the devices
um
there is not a
uniform standard that has been approved
by any entity that oversees elections
that I'm aware of
and so uh you know these devices have
been tested and used in other states but
there have been some pretty dramatic
failures of them in other states too so
when they're used in New Hampshire we
require that they also maintain a paper
checklist so that if they're four hours
into the election things crash
um that they can just revert back to the
paper checklist and keep going as if it
never happened
um idea would it would be nice if we can
get to the point that we're comfortable
enough that we don't have to
require that duplicate effort but for
the time being I think it's it's
important that we do that thank you
further questions
um representative
thank you thank you hello Mr secretary
and
um my question had to do with the ballot
counting devices you said that you're
testing new ones so once and then it
goes I'm interested in the process so
then it goes to the ballot law
commission they select one and then
who's responsible so then all
municipalities upgrade or who pays for
those or how does all that work
so there's several questions in that in
that question the the the process right
now is that
that there are standards
there are federal standards for ballot
counting devices that are used in
elections
and the election assistance commission
which is the federal agency that is
responsible for that
is getting very close now to approving
the next level of standard
um
the the three devices that we are
testing
at the local elections coming up all
have the lower standard but we don't
know yet if they would meet the higher
standard the companies of course claim
that they will
but once the EAC
establishes those standards then
the companies that manufacture the
machines will then
have to make sure their machine meets
the standard and then submit it to a
national you know certified National
Laboratory
for a complete review and confirmation
that yes you know these systems meet the
new standard and that that's the
confidence that we need where the ballot
commission needs to say uh if they
select a device and meets that standard
yeah this is the one that makes the most
sense for New Hampshire
it is not practical for the ballot
commission to approve more than two
devices because New Hampshire is such a
small market for these devices that you
know if we approve more I mean ideally
just one would be would be good because
um
yeah there just isn't enough market here
for the companies to be interested to
give us good pricing and to maintain
them and even Market their product here
um
in terms of who pays for them it is a
local decision whether a town or a city
is going to use a ballot accounting
device to Cather ballots obviously
there's some savings to them by not
doing it by hand which is very time
consuming
um
and I know that there are some
communities that use the devices that
are already setting a certain amount of
money aside so that when the approval is
made they can be purchased
the
the federal government
has released Hopper funds
for specific purposes and
prior to the pandemic there was a good
sized block of money that was issued for
security because if you remember prior
to the pandemic everybody was concerned
about foreign actors hacking into our
systems and so a large sum of money was
issued
to be able to fight that
the then a year later we had the
pandemic and we were issued in excess of
three million dollars to be able to help
fund elections you know with those
conditions and so
we gave all of the three point I think
it was 3.3 million dollars
to the cities and towns
and we did it in two ways we we used
money to purchase uh PPE
masks hand sanitizer big screens that
could protect the ballot clerks from the
um downs and you know all of the
materials you needed in a pulp in a
polling place to keep people safe
and then the balance that the large
balance probably three million dollars
of that money
we simply gave to the cities and towns
on the basis of the number of absentee
ballots
that were issued for that election and
as you know there were roughly three
times the number of absentee ballots
that were cast in that election
which shifted the workload significantly
to the clerk's and the moderators
and in my opinion it was that large
number of absentee ballots that caused
the problem in Windham because they were
dealing with such a volume they decided
to take a shortcut use a letter folding
device that wasn't folding the ballots
properly on the on the and so you know
we ended up with that problem and then
Bedford was dealing with a huge number
of absentee ballots and they just a lot
they lost track of a sack of ballots and
they never got they never got processed
or counted um
and but you can see how it would happen
because of the way they were you know
they were overloaded
um but anyway you know those monies were
dispersed in in that manner now Congress
is has authorized a new round of
additional funding
um
Patty mentioned that it's a million
dollars and we have to provide a 20
State match
to go along with that but because we
have the 12 times amount that we need
um that money could be used to at least
subsidize the purchase of you know
additional voting equipment
um you know that could be just around
the corner
um
you know whether it's ballot counting
machines or whether it's the poll books
I mean I think both of them
will continue to to be improved and you
know will be used more and more in
future elections
I don't see any of the questions uh
seeing none thank you Mr secretary and
the two deputies good to see you all
thank you
all right Marty and company
New Hampshire Retirement System
Marty would say it was the best for last
thank you for having us representative
leishman with me today is Marie Mullin
our Director of Finance who you may
recognize from dot we were able to poach
her this summer and we're very happy to
be able to do that so what we have for
you today and you've got the slides in
front of you is a brief slide deck that
we're just going to kind of walk through
but use it as much as a jumping off
point for questions or you know things
that you want to explore further and
it's it's similar to something we did
for house Insanity DNA a few weeks ago
if we are invited back to full Finance
we'll give you a little bit longer
version of this but we didn't want to
bore you and give you the same thing
twice uh
so so with that I'm going to turn it
over to Marie she's going to walk
through the first half of the slides and
then I'll take the second and there's
some appendix slides at the end that
we're not going to cover but um we may
reference if the question comes up and
it's it's on those
all right well good afternoon everyone
so let's um start out with the contents
we'll do an overview of our membership
and benefits the Investments
contributions and funding legislation
and a summary and again as Marty
mentioned their appendices at the end
so for the high level overview New
Hampshire retirement system is a
contribute contributory multi-employer
defined benefit defined benefit plan
established in 1967. it provides
retirement disability and death benefits
death benefits as well as
post-retirement medical subsidies to
eligible members and beneficiaries
so
you're you're familiar with most
retirement plans at the defined benefit
plan is is a little different where the
disability and death benefits are not
part of most retirement plans but they
are part of the retirement system plans
so once members attain eligibility they
can receive a guaranteed lifetime
pension
and their benefits are funded through
employee and employer contributions
and and investment income
so
because we have a qualified plan that
means that the the contributions that
employees pay are pre-tax and are only
taxed upon distribution
on slide four
uh the New Hampshire retirement system
is a component unit of the state
government so we're not an executive
agency of the state we are a component
unit and it's overseen by a Board of
Trustees
the Board of Trustees and the
independent investment committee are
fiduciaries so as far as fiduciaries we
are required both employees of the
retirement system and the board and
independent investment committee we are
required to act in the best interest of
the members and retirees always not in
our own self-interests but always in the
in the best interest of the retirees
the legislature is the plan sponsor and
all of our rsas are under RSA 100a
and our staff implements the statutes
rules and policies as well as the
Internal Revenue code
one of the most important
um
legislative pieces here is that under
article 36a of the Constitution
These funds are protected for the
exclusive purpose of providing benefits
to the retirement to the retirements and
the retirees and it requires the board
to certify employer rates based on sound
Actuarial practice as well as requiring
employers to pay the rates that are
certified so that is all in the New
Hampshire Constitution
Slide Five
this is a general overall of how the
plan is funded so the contributions from
members and retire and employers
plus the investment income we get from
investing those funds
go into the trust fund and then from
that those funds in the trust fund
benefit payments and expenses go out
so that equation must balance in the
long term so over the long term so in
one individual year you may not have
that balance but over the long term with
the investment returns and the
contributions we're receiving it is
anticipated that they will equal and
that it will it does balance out
currently as of June 30th 22 end of
fiscal year the trust fund had 10.75
billion available funds in there to be
invested
the next slide slide six is a is a graph
showing you over the past 12 years
basically from 2010
which was when the state started the
30-year amortization of the unfunded
liability you can see the the balance in
the the assets of the trust fund have
gradually increased over that time based
on investments and some of the changes
that were made in 2010 to the the actual
assumptions
on slide seven
the the membership of the the retirees
and the and the members is made up of
two groups so there's group one which
make up the employees and the teachers
group two is police and fire
we have 461 active participating
employers all around the state
originally the state employees were were
part of where the retirement system and
then in 1967 it was Consolidated and
municipalities were given the choice to
join and most most do join the
retirement system
um the unfunded Actuarial liability is
paid by the employers over time
currently and Marty will discuss that
later in the presentation and how that
has come about
on slide eight we have some statistics
on our as of June 30th of our current
membership both active and retirees as
far as our active membership that hasn't
remained pretty consistent over the past
10 years we don't see a lot of
fluctuation in that total number of the
48 000 however the retirees have
increased during that time frame and
since 2013 the number of retirees has
increased 43 percent
so when you're looking at that that grid
before of the funds coming in to cover
the expenses
the the active membership has remained
the same but you're seeing the number of
retirees increase so you're going to
have that additional pull on the funds
to be paying these retirees but your
contributions coming in from that
membership are have been pretty stagnant
wasn't that black
um when that gets when the actuaries
review that will that cause a
significant spike in uh fees or the cost
of the plan the contributions required
that's already factored into the current
rates and then into the rates going
forward as as part of the overall that's
you know um you know ideally if if in a
perfect world if we were fully funded
the rates would be much lower but and
the active members would be pre-funding
and the employees would be pre-funding
the benefits as they accrue so that
growing retiree population is a factor
in the assumptions and you know there's
a you know retirement rates and and all
kinds of different assumptions tied to
that that
it shouldn't by itself Drive the rates
up
because it's already cooked in
into the assumptions
okay and over to slide nine
um in fiscal year 22 uh the retirement
system paid out 914 million in benefits
to retirees and beneficiaries
in that same period we paid out 43.8
million to our related to the
post-retirement medical subsidy
um just some information on that medical
subsidy program that is a closed program
and that will decrease over time right
currently there's a little over 90 100
retirees in that plan and as
um those retirees
are deceased and they don't have
beneficiaries then that medical subsidy
will will go down
currently approximately 80 percent of
retirees and beneficiaries remain in New
Hampshire so those those funds are
staying to support the economy of New
Hampshire and in our summary act for
online and some of you may have picked
up I think Marty has left some in some
of the rooms but we do have a breakdown
by County as well so you can see that
Financial impact to each of the counties
throughout the state of the pension and
where where those funds are located
I will turn it over now to Marty to
start with slide 10.
thank you Marie um so membership and
benefits and and I I know this is
repetitive for some folks who've been
here a while and we don't want to put
you to sleep but there are some newer
folks involved with the retirement issue
so we would start right at the beginning
there are four types of retirement
benefits provided by nhrs service
disability early invested deferred
Service retirement is by far the most
common you're old enough you've worked
long enough and you put in your
paperwork and You Begin collecting your
benefit of more than 80 85 percent of
our retirees are service retirees uh
disability retirement there are two
types available in the statute one is
job related and one is non-job-related
and there's different eligibilities and
benefits depending on the type of
disability
um you know but any anybody who is
permanently injured on the job even on
you know the second day of their career
would be able for uh receive an
accidental job-related disability
benefit so the be non-job related you
need to have 10 years in the system to
qualify early retirement is there are
Provisions in the statute that allow
people once they reach a certain age and
number of years of service they can take
a reduced benefit prior to their full
retirement age in the statute and that's
a permanent reduction that would carry
over one stage into full retirement age
as well
not a lot of people do that but it is an
option and then that's the Deferred
retirement this is a type of retirement
where somebody has worked 10 or more
years with nhrs regardless you know
between 25 and 35 or 40 and 50 whatever
you know they take another position or
do something else so they're no longer
an active employee member or you know
any active member of the retirement
system they keep their funds that they
contributed with the retirement system
and they can come back to us when they
age into retirement eligibility and
collect a pension based on those prior
years of service it's obviously going to
be a smaller pension than somebody who
worked a full career but that is an
option for some of our members to choose
that
there are different benefit Provisions
in the statute for group one and for
group two and that that's always been
the case since the plan was set up and
Consolidated back in the 60s however due
to some legislative changes in 2011 now
there are different benefit Provisions
or tiers if you will within each of
those two groups there's three tiers uh
you know members who were vested prior
to January 1st of 2012 have certain
benefit provisions and certain pay types
are counted in their pension members who
are in the retirement system prior to
July 1st of 2011 but not vested prior to
January 1st of 12 or sort of a middle
group and then anyone hired on or after
July 1st of 2011 is in is in the the
third tier and is you know basically the
formulas change a little bit the age
requirements change a little bit for
those people who the farther away from
the original vested cohort in those
stats in the Statue where we were
starting to roll out referring to these
rather than the long-winded string of
dates as tier a b and c
um you know for for brevity and uh
you know um those reasons like that so
um regardless of what tier someone's in
though their benefits are determined
based under statutory formulas and the
the key components of the formulas are
creditable service how long did someone
work average final compensation and
that's
um going to be someone's either their
highest three or highest five years of
um earnable compensation with a
retirement system employer and earnable
compensation was also changed along the
way so some pay types are count for the
the older tra members and don't count
for members in the lower tiers but it's
you know we it's either a three or five
year average and then a benefit
multiplier it's basically formulas to
derive the pension based on you know AFC
time service divided by or multiplied by
X and those those multipliers are
different between group one and group
two and this the six different
multipliers in group two depending on
where they fall on transition ladder at
the time of the legislative changes so
there's a at the end the appendix is
sample calculations for what it would
look like for a group one and a group
two membered hired after uh July 1st of
11 just for reference I mean typically
this committee isn't in the Weeds on
that side you're it's already gone
through a policy committee and you're
looking at the numbers but just wanted
to kind of do a brief overview of how
that all works
if you turn to slide 11 this is just a
sort of a distribution of benefits by
amount
um you know the average benefit on one
of Marie's slides was 21 862
um you know on average for the the 42
000 recipients
um take that number 26 percent see a
benefit of under 10 000 a year uh 64
it's under 25
000 on an annual basis 93 of our
retirees and beneficiaries and benefits
under fifty thousand uh they were or
higher uh pension retirees those making
more than 75 000 is a little bit less
than two percent of the total population
uh those folks tend to be uh people who
work for a large number of years you
know in a you know in certainly at least
their final years were more lucrative in
the job they probably acquired more
responsibilities along the line uh
things like that so you know the the
calculations the same for everyone
regardless of what they're all that the
benefit is there already scheduled
special calcs I'm not sure if we cut it
out of here I think we may have but
there's a there is a benefit
distribution by
um by member group The 21862 is an
aggregate
um
roughly speaking in an average retired
employee the annual benefits about
fifteen thousand
um I think it's about 23 and a half for
a retired teacher somewhere in the
vicinity of 38 or 39 for the retired
firefighter and a little bit over 40 for
a retired
um firefighter
yeah 39 189 for police and 44 350 for
fire and one of the reasons in this
representative Weiler mentioned this uh
yesterday but one of the reasons the the
fire benefit is a little bit higher than
the police benefit is they they
firefighters tend to retire with an
average of two or three more years of
service uh than an average police member
so slide 12 Investments this just talks
about the structure of how the
Investments are managed by nhrs the
board has a very high level
um uh function with with Investments
they're not involved in the direct
operation they approve an investment
policy including an asset allocation how
much are we comfortable allocating to
you know U.S Equity domestic Equity
fixed income real estate
Etc
um and we have an independent investment
committee and that was created by
legislation and the committee um
took effect uh January 1 of 09 so
they've been around for a number of
years now and have had a successful
track record they recommend the
investment policy and investment
consultant for the board to review and
they're the they're the group that meets
monthly and oversees the administrating
the investment program they basically
you know do the hiring and firing of
providers
um you know if we want to go into a
we're changing the allocation or there's
an underperforming manager we'll let
them go or a re-up uh with somebody that
we're happy with so they're the the
working groups uh in terms of investment
they also prepare with staff the
comprehensive annual investment report
and there's a dropped a copy of that off
and Ms clayman's office across the way
uh yesterday
um both the board and independent
investment committees are fiduciaries as
Marie mentioned as they're listed in the
appendix both the board membership and
the iic the iic is separate from the
board there are two trustee members of
the aac3 non-trusty members
in a sixth member who's an active member
of the retirement system
so when everyone on there has to have uh
some experience an Institutional
investment or public finances or
requirements so
um you know that they've proven pretty
successful over time
um slide 13 just shows the investment
returns as of June 30th of 2022 the
one-year return ending last June 30th
was minus 6.1 that was our first
negative number since the Great
Recession
um and you know it's called Comfort to
say we beat our Benchmark which was
minus 9.3 uh but
um when you look at the you know the 3 5
10 and 25 year returns you know they are
above our current assumed rate of return
and tracking in a good direction the
prior year fiscal 21 uh we we had a 29.4
return which may have been the highest
we've ever had so
um this is a good time to talk about
Actuarial smoothing
um and the next slide shows the return
since 2007 on a year-over-year basis and
there's a line that goes along with that
in Gray and that represents five years
smoothing of investment return and
that's how the actuary calculates the um
the employer rates because if you
based employer rates in fiscal 21 on we
made two billion dollars isn't that
great you know the rates would fall
through the floor and then you have a
minus here then they're gonna
undulate wildly so um you know they uh
and this is a fairly standard Actuarial
practice some people do four years you
know six years but you know the five
years is the most common you know so so
that's a rolling average you know one
year drops off and the next year adds on
uh for smoothing and you think that that
line is much straighter and more stable
you know than the ups and downs you know
in the year over year with the markets
so so that that's how smoothing works so
um
you know and it's been very beneficial
because of the five years ending uh June
30th of 21.
um
were were above the assumed rate of
return it was a you know that helped uh
reduce employer rates slightly
um in the next next upcoming biennium
so if you turn to slide 15 it's just a
little um a little back padding uh by
nhrs
um the performance uh through 622 was in
the 80th percentile of of peer Public
Employee Retirement plans of over a
billion in assets uh over the last 10
years
um in over the 13 years since the iic
was formed that were in the top 80
percent as well
um that our performance from 09 through
fiscal 22 represents 325 million in
additional returns if we were just at
the 50th percentile completely average
you know we'd have 325 million less in
the trust fund and you know some some
years you are a genius in some years you
look like a fool and it's they they need
to
um you have thick skins and you know
it's a lot that you know our we're a
long-term investor so it's not like you
know we're gonna you know buy and sell
you know day trade and trade currencies
I mean we're looking for Investments
that can perform over the long term for
the benefit of our members so some some
there's a lot of diversification but
they there there are years where you
know sometimes the bear E2 and sometimes
eat the bear
um
so
um let's see let's let that move to
slide 60 and this is contributions and
this some questions came up yesterday
about this
um member contributions what what the
active members put into the system are
set by Statute
um so um they're an RSA 100a employees
and Teachers Pay seven percent of uh
payroll of their
printable compensation to the retirement
system every pay period police it's
11.55 in fire it's 11.8 the police and
fire have always been higher
contribution in part because uh Public
Safety group two in New Hampshire does
not participate in Social Security so
neither the employer or the member you
know put in that Social Security piece
and and
almost all of our group one members
employers are in Social Security there
are a couple of exceptions that I'm
aware of but um
that that
um
that opted out of the plan before the
federal law changed in the 80s to to
make that no longer an option
um employer contributions however are
set actuarially so the actuary
determines what the rates are required
to be to keep funding the system and
paying benefits and paying down the
liability and then the board certifies
those uh rates on a biennial basis so
every two years
um you know the actually does a
valuation that develops the rates that
goes to the board and it gets approved
we um
the statutorily we have to approve those
no later than October 1st we had always
been doing that in September but this
year we accelerated the process to
approve certify rates in July to give
employers including the state more times
to start building their budget
spreadsheets for the next two years
um you know local employers have paid
100 of the contribution since 2011 with
the exception of the HB 1221
reimbursement this year
just sent that over to Melissa probably
10 minutes before we left the office so
you'll have that
um that number I know representative
Griffin asked for those yesterday
um and um that that's sort of the basics
on that and uh but the the employer rate
uh as we move to slide 17 there are
different components to the employer
rate
um you know I like it liking it to a tax
bill you got your town your county and
your school it's not the same but
mentally you look at the bottom line and
that's what you're paying and that
that's what matters but there are pieces
that flow into that uh the first is the
normal cost and this is the estimated
annual cost of pension benefits as
they're earned so this is the the seven
percent or eleven plus percent that the
members are putting in that's all going
to pre-fund their own benefit and then
the difference
above the statutory rates for the member
the employer picks up that portion of
the normal cost and then the next slide
will kind of show how much that is uh
and I'm going to skip to the bottom of
this slide first and say medical subsidy
and this is as Marie mentioned it's a
closed plan sort of a legacy benefit uh
that offsets insurance premiums for
folks who are receiving insurance
through their former employer
um and that's funded as a pay you go
rate that sure he doesn't calculate a
liability for those accounts per se they
just estimate how much do we need to
bring in to pay the benefit over the
biennium and then the middle section of
the of slide 17 with all the bullets
that is unfunded liability uh this is
you know by far the biggest
conversation topic uh when it comes to
the retirement system this is in a
nutshell it's the estimated of accrued
nhrs benefits not yet funded so this is
benefits promised
in the in the future uh that we don't
have the assets on hand today to pay
today we don't have to pay them today
because these are monthly benefits paid
over people's lives but you are much
happier and better off if you are close
to full funding than digging out of a
hole
um
5.69 at the close of fiscal 22 5.69
billion I'm sorry and that's a funded
ratio of 65.6 so we have a little bit
less than two-thirds of all the
funds we needed if you just you shut the
doors on everything today and we were
just paying benefits you know for the
lifetime of everyone who's earned
benefit
um so how do we have a liability that's
a it's a it's an obvious question and
it's a it's a good question especially
with the Constitutional provision that
we have that you know employers need to
pay the rates in full
um you know there's a
I I'm going to give you a long story
that I'm going to say is the short
version
of that and I I you know I do apologize
but
um there are several factors and policy
decisions made in the 80s and 90s that
led to the liability the first was
artificially low employer contributions
charged from 1991 through
um through the and repeat that and
repealed until 2007. the backdrop there
and I you know I recognized some long
time New Hampshire folks I was here at
the time as well although I'm not a
native uh but there was a there was a
recession in the early 90s Savings and
Loan crisis let out a lot of people were
underwater with the condos many of the
state's long-established Banks went
under
um and and the employer rates were
projected to go up in 92-93 based on
some benefit improvements to the plan
that the legislature had adopted back in
89. so you know they with the lag on the
way the rates are calculated that was
showing up the rates were extremely
lower than they are today but as a
percentage increase you know you could
say oh they're going for from four
percent to six percent that's a fifty
percent increase I mean it's you know
type of thing so so there was a lot of
pressure
to do something about that from local
employers you know from the governor's
office at the time you know what what
can happen you know the legislature you
know was strapped as well
um and what happened was House Bill 51
and that um was a billed initially as a
temporary
rate amelioration legislation that
changed the Actuarial method that we
calculated rates by basically changing
the underlying math there were at the
time for
caught acceptable under gasby and
Actuarial standards ways to calculate
pension liabilities now there's only one
um that meets those standards but um the
the sort of the gold standard and I was
actually recommended by a consultant for
us in 91 was entry age normal
um you know but in their report on
funding methodologies they had a second
page on the executive summary that said
uh well there's other four types these
other three types are acceptable either
you know
they're a little expensive because of
the way they push the liabilities else
father and you're in a recession you've
got people with pressure and you know
you know well-meaning legislators trying
to do the best they can and they chose
the cheapest way
you know so so we we created sort of a
systemic underfunding the employers were
meeting their constitutional ability to
requirement to pay the rates that the
board certified but the the math you
know I guess the scientific term would
be funky
um you know and then that was uh kept in
stature uh through 07 when it was
finally repealed so it didn't really
show up until the 10 rates
um work their way into the system so
that that's I liken it to you know going
downstairs in a boat and drilling a
couple holes in the bottom and
forgetting about it and then you feet
get wet 15 years later and you say hey
what's going on
um
you know there was some other uh
laws where investment gains over a
certain amount were segregated to pay
for cost of living adjustments and and
for the medical subsidies well they were
sort of put into what was called a
special account
so in years where investment returns
were really good
um you know not all the money stayed in
the trust fund to pay pension benefits
so when you had a year where it wasn't
so good there wasn't any
left over to fill the hole so so you
know we in the 90s kind of glossed over
to a lot of the the structural issues
with this I think eight years out of
nine we were in double digits you know
sometimes you know 15 to 20 percent you
know the 90s were very good uh to
investors
um and then in the early 2000s we had
the.com recession and and that that was
sort of a wake-up call
um you know for policy makers employers
and members and there were discussions
about you know are we in a good place
um
you know so so over a period of years
there were like working groups and
legislative groups and um beginning in
2007 uh with House Bill 653 they re they
changed the actual method the two entry
age normal they set up a 30-year close
the amortization of the unfunded
liability uh and uh you know shut off
additional funding to the special
account under the previous triggers you
know really foundational structural
stuff that needed to be fixed you know
you have an old house and you got to
show up the basement walls kind of thing
um and then beginning in 08 some benefit
uh modifications were put in not not
super dramatic but there were some pay
types that were taken out of earnable
compensation and some laws about
um spiking was a big issue back then for
people uh building their pension so you
know everybody pulled together and got
it fixed and then what happened the
Great Recession so you know basically
you know that that was sort of a tsunami
on top of the earthquake so you know if
you look at the unfunded liability in 07
it was about 2.4 billion and it's over
five now how we've got a plan and we're
going to tell you it's working how come
it's grown so much and and
representative Griffin has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um was there ever a time that we didn't
have an unfunded liability under the
Actuarial methodology in place through
the 90s it didn't really calculate a
funded ratio as as part of the overall
the way they did it but they they the
actuary at the time it's a different
x-ray now would
um calculate a funding funded ratio
somehow and we were like oh we're 120
funded you know you know so there were
numbers and back in the 80s there was
some after some some good market run-ups
then uh you know we were over 100 funded
you know over time but I I don't know
what
under the proper actual method if we're
ever 100 funded in the 90s but you know
we were told we were
um you know by the experts thank you
yeah so so a lot of that liability That
Grew um from 07 came out of the Great
Recession uh about uh 1.7 billion the
decennial retirement Commission in 2017
um okay we commissioned an analysis of
you know what were the components that
grew into the break it was a little bit
over five at the time and it was the
Great Recession was the biggest driver
um as well as something called negative
amortization which our our rates weren't
paying into the principle of the
liability until later on in the 30-year
period we did have crossed over since
then you know plus uh reductions to our
assumed rate of return so um you know it
wasn't all policy I mean our board has
lowered our assume rate of return in in
three different steps since 2011 from
eight and a half percent to six point
seven five percent and basically when
you
um assume less money then this the money
has to come from somewhere and it comes
out of employer contribution so you know
we we would we would contend that
or in the assumed rate of return is the
fiduciary responsible thing to do we
can't have wishful thinking and just
hope we're going to make nine percent
um you know uh but you know so so they
they need to be realistic the actuary
doesn't come and say this is what your
number should be
um but every four years they do what's
called an experience study and they they
have an aggregate of Capital Market
um projections they have from other
um you know Financial firms that they
Aggregate and leave that with us we have
other input from from our investment
managers and other other folks and he
actually kind of gives us a range of
where they're comfortable actually they
could sign off and say this is a sound
peace you know and you know six and six
six and three quarters was was at the
high end of what they would have
preferred in 2019 but that that's
um
you know where the board came down so
those are probably the hardest decisions
our board has to make is looking at
assumptions and in particular the assume
rate of return
um because there's a lot of
um you know political pressures you know
make the number work and and we've been
blessed to have a number of different
trustees over the last decade who really
put on their trustee hat and they're not
representing you know town of X or
County y or you know
fire department be you know they they
look at it and try to you know make
their vote in the best interest of the
system overall
um so so those those those were
self-inflicted additions to the unfunded
liability but ones that we argue were
more financially
um
beneficial in the long run we do have a
statutory structure to amortize five
billion of the the 5.7 uh by 2039 that's
the original 30-year plan uh that was
adopted by the legislature back in 07 uh
in 2018
uh they adopted something called layer
demonization and basically what that
does is any gains or losses since uh
July 1 of 17 are recognized over close
20-year periods so basically the idea
and this this came out of the decennial
commission as well as if
everything had to be paid off and we had
to be 100 funded by the end of 2039.
um
you know what if there was a stock
market crash or a recession in 2038 and
employee player rates quadrupled you
know what good is that for anybody so so
they they and layered amortization as a
concept that's been gaining traction a
lot of uh States
um have adopted it so it's like
basically for what happens after
the big debt gets later put down what do
we do going forward and this this will
having layers and having the the
statutory structure we do now
you know our our safeguards on
preventing the liability growing to the
size it has in the you know in the past
you know I mean we're still digging out
from that hole but
um you know what we've done is you know
the regulatory statutory and policy
structure that can
get us to where we want to go
um
took it out but there was a reference to
um Maine had a similar pension funding
problem to New Hampshire
um and they began addressing in the mid
90s the past Constitutional Amendment
they have the same Actuarial method
similar
um size membership
um things like that they were actually
more poorly funded than New Hampshire
ever was uh and they got serious about
fixing it about 10-12 years before we
did so we look at them as an example
um you know and you know there's a lot
of sim I'll follow up with a a a paper
on that that we did but um you know
there in the 86 funded now so it you
know the you know and they also
benefited out of the shoot from some
pretty good Market years and you know
the late 90s where we fixed it and then
spun into a ditch with a Great Recession
so that that added to the degree of
difficulty but you know we've shown
steady uh even with the reduction as the
consumerator return steady progress and
the funded ratio
I Grew From
54.7 percent uh to um the 65.6 over the
last 10 years
so so um there may or may not be
yeah
um so you know so so that that's where
we're at right now uh you know nobody
from nhrs is going to come here and say
hey we fixed it done take a bow uh
everyone in the room I mean we're we're
on our we're on a path we're on it we're
on a good path we're showing progress
but it's a long journey 2039 is still a
long time away and a lot can happen so
so you know we need you know we need to
meet good stewards and and
um you know of watching over that fund
and managing it wisely and efficiently
um slide 18 shows the uh contribution
rates for fiscal 24-25 so those are the
ones taking effect this July 1st and it
breaks out the normal cost the unfunded
liability and the medical subsidy
portion of those rates in the columns to
the left and then on the far right is
the total employer rate by group uh the
gray column in the middle is unfunded
liability as a percentage of the total
pension costs so when you add the ual
piece and the normal cost together for
the employers how much of that as uaal
and it's it's 77 to 85 percent depending
on the the member group so you know
employee employers and and by extension
taxpayers today are
paying for the sins of the past
um you know and having 20-year layered
amortization and getting this big nut uh
knocked down will prevent that from
happening in the future but be
unfortunate you know reality is you know
the person who owns your house in 1997
really wasn't paying what they should
because we weren't charging for these
rates and in Europe here now
um you know but that that's where we're
at at the bottom of the chart it shows
the membership of the normal cost what
their statutory contribution represents
as a percentage of how much they're
putting in uh to their own benefit
Marty do you have a a little history of
what the unfunded liability percentage
contribution was for the last 10 years
so we could see if it's grown has it
decreased it's just stayed the same I
can I can dig out that and send it over
yeah
um and and you're gonna see that the
unfunded liability rate even the rates
themselves are going to change you know
um every
four to five years because of experience
studies those are the pieces where we
lowered the assumed rate of return
therefore the liability on paper became
larger so the rates are going to go up
it's the the goal of trying to fund
um the the liability the way we're doing
it now is to have
um you know relatively stable rates over
the last 30 years it hasn't been the
case because you know we kept hitting
these waves along the way but if if
things smooth out the rates as they are
now well what the goal is is those
aren't going to vary much you know
they'll drop dramatically after 2039 but
they're not going to go up a huge amount
or down a huge amount until we get
through that that five billion piece but
I can get you the basically a rate
representation you know for the last 10
years to show for the committee
so I have another question that comes up
occasionally especially right now where
employees don't have a lot of folks to
pick from hiring is becoming a problem
so as an example say a police chief
retires he's got 25 years in and the
town comes back to him and says hey
could you be our touted Minister
administrator again
he's collecting his retirement
does he still participate in the system
coming forward so he's paying in as say
the New Town Administrator for the town
and how does that affect his retirement
or does once he retires from that
position is there like a re-retirement
or
it's it's a good example because it
shows some of the um the nooks and
crannies and the statute overall so
um Town administrators or chief
administrative officers of a community
um have had have a uh the the governing
body the you know County Commission or I
mean that County this is local you know
the Selectmen or the the um
uh Town Council have the right if when
hiring a chief administrative office
officer to exempt them from membership
in the retirement system so in that
scenario that police chief could say
well I want to be a member
um which really wouldn't increase their
benefit that much and they would lose a
couple of automatic benefits from
retiring as a group too or they could
take their pension that they retired
from under group two and still collect
whatever salary if the position was
properly Exempted under the the
statutory exception that that exception
has been around since the 70s
um you know there's a bill um winning
its way over that would extend it to the
10 counties
um I think that came out of Edna on a
pass I don't think it's on the consent
for tomorrow so so there are some
positions where uh membership is
optional or the position can be Exempted
um if that police chief wanted to become
a commissioner of safety that's another
optional membership the person appointed
to though because it's a fixed term
appointment and folks appointed to fixed
terms have the option to participate in
the retirement system or not now if you
if that
police chief for fire chief want you
know they asked them to be the finance
director that's there's no exemptions
for that if it was a full-time job the
person would have to you know enroll as
a group one not collect any pension from
nhrs until they wrap that job up but
there are certain positions where
they're either membership optional or
the the governing body can exempt it
um you know and I'm not sure the history
of the the hows and whys of of where
these what why these positions are all
out out of the bounds but there are a
few
could you get us a list of those
positions that are exempt from
participating in the retirement system
yes I mean it'll not
you know not in the four page list of
titles but you know you know officials
appointed for fixed terms uh certain
employees of the general court uh you
know um things like that that
membership's optional for so yeah I can
I can definitely get you that thanks
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Carlin so um I'd like to direct you to
um slide number 24 in the appendix which
is sort of similar to 18 although one
line is a little different so I think
there's a typo and one or the other of
them but
um can you explain
why are teachers so different than other
group one categories okay yeah this so
slide 24 is it it represents the current
FY 22 23 rates versus the upcoming uh
newly certified FY 24 and the percentage
change
biennium over bienniums you know all the
rates did go down a little bit
um the the teacher uh percentage in
group one is higher than employees for a
few factors one is planned demographics
that teachers tend to work longer and
make more money than employees on
average and the teacher plan if this
came up yesterday until we're talking
about separate
um funded ratios for each of the plans
but you know we there's an aggregate
funded ratio for the overall system and
the teacher uh plan probably has the
lowest funded ratio of the four part of
the reason for that is the decline in
the number of active teachers you know
we the actuary assumes a flat head count
that doesn't it doesn't just project
that you know they're going to keep
hiring employees and teachers and
everyone else across the state but they
don't assume it's gonna shrink either
um and we saw between 09 and 17 or 18
about a thousand fewer active teachers
in the you know
um in the retirement system those
numbers have grown you know I think we
added 100 or two years ago and 100 more
over the price 200 more over the prior
year so we've seen a little bit of a
bump in that but you know basically what
you're saying is the you'd have a
portion of the rate that you're paying
the liability on you're assessing that
and the employer is on the side the
total payroll of the group of teachers
and even if teachers got raises there's
so fewer of them you know the the
unfunded piece per dollar
um you know gets higher we still still
need to get the money back that way so
that that's why the teacher rate is a
little more out of whack than uh that
and some of some of the difference being
the increase the cost above employer
over above employees is also the medical
subsidy rate is a little bit higher for
teachers
um it's one point one three percent of
pay uh versus
um 0.58 and 0.26 and again the medical
subsidy benefit was open to the teacher
group roll out longer the legislation
repealed it for Employers in the early
2000s and they didn't repeal the teacher
medical subsidy until 09. so so there's
factors that go into that higher rate
and you know the head count
um and and the subsidy or the two big
ones thank you now why did
um the current Year's rates go down when
you lost money last year shouldn't they
go up
so so again it all comes down to the
timing of the rates so in
um odd numbered fiscal year is 19 23 25
Etc that the the battery does evaluation
and that's the the rate setting
valuation so the 24 25 rates were based
on the um
June 30th of 21 you know which was the
29.4 year but that's smooth but even
with that the five years were flush
enough where the rates were a little bit
uh went down a little bit
um you know and we get a question it's
like don't you just keep them the same
I'd rather just kind of pay ahead a
little and it's like
you really need to follow the actuary on
this one you can
put your thumb on the scale one way or
the other because it just creates a bad
precedent so I mean I we wish they'd
stayed the same as well but I mean you
know certainly there was a dramatic
increase
um 2021 to 22 23
um because of of assumption changes
lowering the assumed rate of return so
this does give employers a little bit of
a breather but you know we
gotta gotta trust the math on that and
not play with it so that's why they went
down
thank you could I ask some more detailed
question so
um our employees on the benefit side our
employees allowed when they retire to
take a two life benefit versus a one
life benefit if they're married can they
yes fixed and yeah we have in the
stasher they're referred to as
survivorship options so you can leave
um if you take the maximum benefit it's
calculated a certain way and it goes to
you for life and then you know if
there's any money left of your
contributions that weren't yet paid out
to you that would go to your beneficiary
the lump sum payment or you can choose a
survivorship option
um typically either 50 or 100 percent of
the benefit
um and and there's a reduction to the
benefit from the get-go when somebody
chooses a survivorship option it's it's
all predicated on a life expectancy of
the member and the beneficiary
um you know for the multiple lives so if
you chose a survivorship option and you
wanted to do 50 of your benefit for a
spouse who's similar in age to you the
reduction is going to be less than if
you want to leave 100 to your child you
know because that person is going to
live a lot longer you know when it's a
larger benefit so so those
um life expectancy natural tables are
updated every four years as part of the
experience study so so that that's the
design to account for the two lives
I see thank you and last question is how
much gain does the does the system get
from employees who leave before they're
vested
uh in terms of I don't know dollar
amount or percentage
um if if a return if someone Works more
than six months and then would terminate
service you know whether by choice or
otherwise
um you know so they're no longer
contributing they have invested yet
because they haven't put in 10 years
um they're entitled to their their
contributions that they put in plus
credited interest but the trust fund
keeps the employer contributions put in
on behalf if it's less than six months
we re we do reimburse the employer
um for that
um but um so so anybody who doesn't make
it to vesting and doesn't come back in
later invest all that that money pays
other people's benefits you know and
that that that's that's sort of the
magic of the of the defined benefit
there's you know somebody's going to
live to 110 and unfortunately you know
somebody's gonna die six months after
they retire but when you have a large
pool of people you know that's gonna
even out you know you know you know in
the big picture
right but my question is can you give me
a number in terms of
um how much that did the did the system
grab from that person compared to their
own what they what their own
um contribution to the plan was at that
when they left say somebody leaves after
eight years okay so there's a certain
amount in the system that's if came from
the employer the system's going to keep
versus what they're going to return to
the guy from their seven percent or
whatever they put in over time you see
what I mean yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
start and ask for me to jump in if if
you know otherwise from the finance side
but I mean it to my knowledge all of the
employer contributions come in and
they're all credited to the Chicago
State accumulated annuity trust fund is
a lump
um you know the member contribution they
were accounted for separately you know
for cases in which somebody withdraws or
you know there's a benefit to be paid
but you know like you know pan over or
you know Lebanon isn't paying in
for representative McGuire the opinion
for everybody works for Lebanon and all
that money just goes into the to a big
sack so um you know we could if we had
to you know
for a legal reason or something try to
tease it out like okay what was the
employer contribution rate in in effect
for the years that this person worked
but there's no easy we don't account for
that
um in any of our normal reporting
um because it's just considered you know
part of the you know I guess maybe
another question another way to ask the
same thing is
how many do 50 of the people who start
on day one end up vesting 10 years later
or is it 85 percent or is it 35 you know
what what fraction of people who start
employment in in the system end up
becoming vested
is that something you could answer
yeah
when the actor doesn't experience study
every four four to five years it's it's
on a four-year schedule now they look at
you know withdrawals over you know
periods of time so we may have you've
got a
super duper Deluxe
you know spreadsheet that covers
everything but it can show patterns and
then maybe we can if maybe they're in
their analysis there's some percentage I
mean it's it's you know I mean even if
you wanted to pick a specific year right
yeah all the people that got hired in
look at 2010 how many are still left
right you know something like that that
might not be too hard to do anyways I'd
like I'd like to get that day yeah we'll
we'll check into that yeah thank you
definitely and get you an answer either
way you know whether it's what we have
and
and we can pull it together
maybe it's just a quick follow-up to
representative Maguire's question just
perhaps this last year how many people
exited uh that will obviously not
receive the 10-year vesting just even a
yearly how many people average during
the course of a year may exit the system
okay
try try to get
triangulate something that is responsive
as as we can for for the question uh
definitely
um
didn't want to add one thing about the
the the the withdrawal you know folks
who don't who work and don't invest that
that's also an Actuarial assumption you
know a percentage of that and that that
goes into the rates there is an
expectation that some people for for
whatever reason aren't gonna make it all
the way to go you know they're gonna
stop playing the game at some point so
so that that is built into the
assumptions as well already
a representative from Windham that's not
on the division but he's been trying to
get my attention but you're welcome to
sit right up in that vacant seat and use
the mic to ask you a question
thank you Mr chair and it's not really a
question and I promise not to interrupt
often but since you are asking that
question I am one of the employees who
is technically right now not vested
because I served to the town for six and
a half if you ask those questions I
would be one of the people who doesn't
qualify for retirement but there is
always the possibility that at some
point later I will complete my other
three years and a half so you gotta be
just careful about how you ask those
questions because I think I know what
you're getting to but this may not be
the data set that will answer you know
the question of how much money at some
point is vested but never you know is
paid but never invested into so I don't
want to get too geeky I don't want to
hijack the conference but I just wanted
to quickly make that point and I'll go
back to my seat as soon as you are done
sure and you might have it when you get
close to 65 you might have a big a good
incentive to work another five years
just to get that thing right so yeah I
agree
um yeah I was speaking to a member of
the AG's office recently a guy who's in
his early 40s and he's leaving after
eight and a half years believe it or not
because he just can't he's got four kids
and a stay-at-home wife and he can't
afford to keep doing it and so he's
leaving a lot of money on the table so
I'm just wondering is that a big effect
is it a one in a hundred effect who
knows right
into the representatives point I know I
know we wouldn't have any data on this
but there you know it was always people
who leave before vesting can come back
um because sometimes you know when when
there's layoffs it is an involuntary
separation and they're hoping to get
back they're on a riff list or something
uh we see you know people taking breaks
in service you know to raise small
children things like that but they're
expect planning to go back you know to
the classroom or whatever you know they
do things like that so so you know it
you know members do have after you know
a short period have they can withdraw
their contribution to their money I mean
your question is about the employer's
money
um you know but you know they can keep
it with us and let it ride or they can
take it out or roll it over into
something else at any point as well
um to just
I'll go right ahead I'm just gonna say
just to wrap it up I I probably went way
over and I apologize
um you know we you know just some
summary slides here you know we provide
a modest pension benefit
um you know a little bit over 20 under
22 000 I guess is the best way to put it
the majority of those folks who are
collecting those benefits remain in
state pay their property tax bills go
out to eat with that money pay the rooms
and meals tax uh we have a plan in place
to pay down our unfunded liability and
manage volatility going forward and you
know the board has besides the steps the
legislature has taken over the last 15
or so years the board has been trying to
take responsible steps to ensure proper
funding uh regarding the assumed rate of
return and things like that
um you know we do have this the
Constitutional and statutory foundation
in place to get the job done it's it's
it would be very difficult for our
future policy makers to walk away from
these obligations with the structure we
have in place now and it is a marathon
not a Sprint uh it took years to dig the
hole that we're coming out of now and
it's going to take twice as long to get
back out of there but you know the you
know the the progress is being made as
seen in the funding ratio so
um like I said again not not a time to
declare Victory but a time to declare
progress uh you know um going ahead try
to try not to oversell uh so that that's
the end of the slide portion
um so I'll be glad to try to answer more
questions or if you want to talk to Mr
Downing now
are there any uh additional questions
well thank you very much excellent
um again I know the dot misses you have
heard that
um
yeah
well I'm glad you used the short long
version because usually Marty just
points to me when he talks about the
unconscious liability it's a try to
explain why we're in a hole because he
was molecular in 88 89.
he knows he was part of that
[Music]
uh thank you
oh no problem no problem
oops again my name is Craig Downing
executive director of the Deferred
Compensation Plan
um it is a voluntary plan we have
approximately 40 percent of current
state employees that are contributing
um there is no State money involved in
the operation of the plan or in the plan
itself there's no employer contribution
uh to the participants retirement this
is in addition to Social Security and
the nhrs pension uh it has its own
special it's called a 457 plan it it
operates like a 401k plan for public
employees whatever the contribution is
that that the participant voluntarily
gives does not count against has no
effect on the pension benefit or their
social security
everything their contributions are net
of Social Security
um as you can see the uh you know some
agencies are better than others this
plan was established in 1977 when they
passed the 457 Act took a couple of
sessions to get it up and running a lot
of changes in the law or additions in
um I began in 89 after I
finished my session
in the legislature setting uh
studying the pension system up
for their unfunded liability Marty
claims that he's got a voting record but
I
he's not produced it
um so I began the state 89 with not a
thought that I was going to continue to
be a state employee and I remember at
orientation I got a similar piece of
information I threw it in the trash
because I wasn't going to retire from
the state I was in my late 20s well 32
years later and 24 of those at Labor
here I am so I I joined on my fifth year
anniversary when a co-worker advised me
that uh
I was closer to the pension than I was
to the front door
and I think I started that paycheck in
the middle of July like 10 or 15 dollars
and the if you all as you all know the
time value of money if I'd started with
that 10 or 15 the day I'd started work
um you'd be talking to my successor
today because the Deferred Compensation
account is probably the best regulator
of when I can afford to retire
um
that the state didn't do a very good job
on this and I think probably if we think
about the exempt employees the
commission level that can choose the
lawyers at doj which can choose if they
want to be in the plan or not if they
want to be in the retirement plan or not
excuse me this was seen I think probably
the legislature at the time is this
plane is a little as a little bonus that
we can provide for those workers so it
was never promoted uh to any extent I
got on the commission we have an
eight-member commission I got on the
Commission in 2007 when I was still at
the Department of Labor because I was
investing I was getting better returns
at a lower cost outside the plan
um we've really done a generational
change since then we talk about the
um
the first market crash that caused the
the unfunded liability I joined the
organization I had to fight to join the
organization go to Baltimore for a
National Conference
and uh
it happened when at the conference and
we watched we stood in the hotel lobby
and watched the stock market go off the
cliff and I thought what have I gotten
myself into but time has cured that and
uh just like it's it's uh is curing it
for the pension
um
it's it's I think this is the The
Greatest Secret still in state
government
um that the state has gotten much better
in promoting it
um and we're it's now part of the
onboarding process I believe at every
single agency
uh and the division of personnel has
done an excellent job in creating an
onboarding system
we still don't have a very standard
off-boarding system there is a limited
amount of
of
interaction between the pension system
and the Deferred Compensation Plan
they obviously we don't give advice on
on the vice versa plans but if someone
is talking about they have a huge leave
balance the retirement system has been
known to give them my phone number or
talk to them about the Deferred
conversation plan as a way to defer
those leave balances likewise since
we're doing in-person meetings and and
did through all of last year and
retirement system was at one point only
doing web meetings we were passing out
brochures to State Employees retiring
that gives them a heads up and how they
can plan to get the documents ready for
their retirement with the pension system
so there's a little bit of informal
cooperation but other than that
any state or political subdivision in
the state can belong to the state plan
and benefit from the
448 million dollars in Assets in our
plan so any town can join in their
employers their employees get the same
rates and Investments That a state
employee can get and the reason I
mentioned the amount of the plan
even though it's way less uh
when we we reached 500 million I started
calling it a half a billion because it
sounded like more money
um
even even though you're in the town of
say a town with like you know two dozen
employees you can get the states rate uh
and benefit from the large Assets in the
plan because that's how the costs are
allocated in this the plane is currently
out to bid
um we have a we go through bids about
five to seven years
um right now you know we expect costs to
drop about 25 percent with whoever the
new company is even if we re-up with the
current vendor
um so as assets go up our costs go down
most towns you know as I say the state
did not promote this to its own
employees or Municipal Employees but if
you were to go into a town and sometimes
some towns or cities have multiple plans
our costs are half as much so literally
it's it's we can give somebody a 50
reduction in fees by transferring into
our plan or establishing it so I don't
know if one of your towns that you
represent is on that list but if they're
not you might have somebody give me a
call
there
I'd be happy to take questions
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Downey
um you said when you handed out this
large piece of paper that we don't spend
this much so presumably all the stuff at
the top is your salary and your benefits
and so on so you do spend that much so
it's either the 45 000 or the 145 000 at
the bottom that we're not spending is
that correct no this is
I think we are I haven't got the exact
cost but I think we we spent 20 226 000
last year
so that was significantly less because
the contracts that I had budgeted came
in well under budget
which would be the 140 the last line yes
there's about 50 000 in there that's
that was more than great thank you very
much
competitive bidding through GNC
contracts
further questions
so I see as far as your investment asset
breakdown
uh 37 U.S stocks how does that compare
to the New Hampshire retirement system
do you happen to know or maybe Marty
knows that's on the page two of six of
the Deferred Compensation Plan
handout
these are self-selected by members so
other than the t row price Target date
funds which is a mix of assets stocks
and bonds based on your birthday
uh and the age you'll turn 65.
participants move their own money and
decide where they go oh okay
any further questions
I'm sure representative McGuire's wife
would love him to get moving right
[Laughter]
well seeing no other questions thank you
very much for your presentation it was
very helpful
thank you very much
all right we'll see everybody at session
tomorrow
no division one tomorrow